[Music]
hey guys hi hey what podcast
okay uh are you ready to go
i didn't sometimes it feels like
the week is too short in terms of like
oh [ __ ] we gotta do another one of these
but uh i don't feel like that as much as
you no i know because i have to [ __ ]
lay the [ __ ] out get the emails and put
them in a thing and
you'll do it sometime and you'll stop
smirking i'm just saying
i mean don't you do it the more the day
up yeah but it's still a pain in the ass
but i just mean the whole week is no but
i gotta worry about i have to
put [ __ ] down if you think about what to
say but it's a process
okay i believe um and uh
this week was long
even by america 20 20 weeks this was a
this was we
i'm gonna do i'm nominated for a week of
the year
it might have been week of the year for
just [ __ ] crazy what the [ __ ]
um i are we it's just
you think it can't get worse and then
trump's like
it can get worse i just i our simulation
is [ __ ]
yes what like i don't get it uh
i don't i just well let's personally
what did you do this week
oh my god i don't you start because i
don't remember
i got my nose i got a beautiful nose job
uh
and it was
impatient they just like put
needles oh i have the i sent you the
picture the yeah it was like the beak
and you literally goes what the [ __ ] is
this and i was like oh it's my nose
well i'll forward it to you because it's
horrifying i really
thought it was it literally looks like a
bird a pregnant bird
can you do this profile from bird x-ray
okay did it get smaller no it didn't no
one you ain't touching the bump
trust me honey why shave off a little
because it's
i don't think you need to for a from for
a
man my age to get a nose job would be
the saddest
to get like a cosmetic job
like kill me
even though you probably wouldn't notice
because my note like it's
the bump has been away under my nose
i've had glass for five years now so
prob people may not remember how what
the bump was like
wait you've only had glasses for five
years yes why
that's so weird i didn't have it's like
starting to smoke at 37.
no except that your vision gets bad
in your 30s but you're you always wear
glasses i didn't wear glasses until five
years ago no sorry you wear them all the
time
now i do yeah is your vision that bad i
thought
when you grow older it's that well
there's that one
but but i had both i'm lucky
i have both uh so i've had glasses for
five years
and it's masked it's like the best and
it just it it sits really nicely on the
bump
a lot of people who don't have strong
bridges or i think that's what they're
called uh they can't wear gloves
i don't think that's true i have a
friend
and she her nose just it swoops in a
little bit more
and then her nose comes out and it
always they fall
so it's really hard for her to wear
glasses it's hard for her
um pray for her
they so i got like needle like topical
lotion whatever like topical it's all in
the nostril
like topical [ __ ] so you couldn't
feel your nose anesthesia then they
hit it with a needle anesthesia
and not anesthesia whatever um yeah i
guess
it's not anesthesia whatever makes it
yeah
and um and then they take a
radio frequency thing and just press it
against
any cartilage that's like in the in the
way of the nostril
the way of the nostril have you seen the
way the nostril it's one of my one of
the best
unseen movies of the 2010s um
and so far so good
i it it's still swollen wait what does
it do it liquidizes paper
it takes the cartilage and literally
just like
like just makes it small like like
a super villain went like heroin like
you just
go into shriveled thing it shrivels it
basically
so it's all there nothing comes out
nothing comes up
though i may have to go back if it
doesn't work to get some stuff out
to get some more made up yeah so that'll
be great that'll be
fun what did it smell like nothing
like nose it wasn't like my flesh
um it was it was fine it was like okay
it didn't smell like anything now the
next one
slicing the next one is slicing so
pray for me if you keep me in your
prayers um
i did that i i'm getting an irish
passport yeah it's so funny somehow
i don't know the rules my sister got an
irish passport
and she did all the certifications yep
well you want to have your i'm trying to
leave my options open i know it's true
um
me and i don't want to we're we're in
me in america and it's complicated right
now you're not entanglement
yeah so they so i'm gonna get an irish
passport
i don't understand how [ __ ] works
because all four of my grandparents were
born in ireland
and my sister went and got the birth
certificates so your sister did all the
did the actual work yeah by the way you
know what my grandmother was born
1896. oh
that's so long ago she had my mom late
and my mom had me late
and now i'm late um like so
it's a hundred you end up like 120 it's
just a lot of years
yeah it's many many did you ever meet
your grandma
no i my mom didn't she had my mom and
then died two years later
what yeah pretty great uh
so yeah i've never met her irish should
have that's so irish oh
i never told you i should have talked
about this on the on the love episode
so my mom's mom died
and the assumption was this is 1935.
the assumption was well a man can't take
care of
his kids how many kids were there three
oh okay four
okay and it was just assumed like well
so my real grandmother told her sister
like
hey take my kids when i die
married like shack up no not no not mary
like
take each one of you take one take one
of my kids
and like my real grandfather
nothing he didn't have to deal with any
kid
and then he ended up marrying he yeah
just like [ __ ] crazy
so my s my mom and her sisters all got
split up oh i remember this story yeah
and then
and then my sis my one of my aunts got
stuck in ireland for ten years
cause of hitler she just got
stuck talk about like
like what you were in at that you know
the way you were stuck in ireland
similar situations
exactly due to a weird fascist person
maybe
right do you get do you see this
basically i'm basically your
yeah you're my you're my own aunt
and uh so pray for me i'll be getting an
irish passport
but pray for ireland pray for ireland
pray i'll bianca i'm going to go to the
wedding
yeah yeah you know what you are going to
ireland
i i'm not her name was becky i'm not
john i'm over seven
i'm not dying to go to ireland i've been
there a lot here's the deal
really cool um terrible weather
so that's like a vacation with bad
weather it's bad it's like
it looks like narnia it's not it's just
green
it's really green it's really oh the
people are so nice
that see that's the thing about ireland
i don't buy no they're
legitimately the nicest people they act
like they're nice no no they are
truly nice i'm in an irish body every
day you're an american irishman no no no
no
different it's you're in like houses my
grandfather
like my gran my dad's my dad's
parents tried to give him away his they
was it was a different time
no i know but i'm saying like these are
the people that you're dealing with
i the thing that you may not sense about
ireland
is the [ __ ] seething anger that
there's a lot of domestic violence right
but it pulses in all these like
when irish eyes are smiling but
meanwhile he's like if he comes at me
again
yeah there's some there's some struggles
there's struggles in ireland
there's internal struggles like the
they're so macho
it's really yeah the men don't heal
this is like this is a wound yeah this
is a wound it's not a country
they're blacker than black men the
irishman there are there's black irish
different thing but no i i but they're
very
they're so nice they yes they seem
i did cast the irish woman out at on the
way back but
she was being a racist she's being a bad
girl
she's being um we'll spare you the story
but she told me
what did you say to her uh she was like
you don't act like that in this country
no you not you're not from here don't
act like that in my country
can you believe and then went to some
like somebody else was like
something weird and i was like by the
way i'm still not on her not on your
side yet no no i'm in the middle right
now
wow you're gonna have to even know what
happened i don't know what happened i
need you to tell me
okay because i've uh okay i'll tell you
this all right
so basically we're getting ready so when
the plane lands and i wonder
your take of this plane lance okay i
don't get up immediately i let
especially people in front of me go and
get their [ __ ] i waited the lady was in
like the isle kitty corner to me one row
up
i waited she was on her phone texting
for a while and now
things were moving so i was like well
you know sorry [ __ ]
i'm not gonna wait till you're good and
ready so i got up
and i got my stuff down and she forced
her way into the
one aisle where someone's she just
forced her way in
while i was standing there and she kept
bending over
and i could feel her butt cheeks like
spreading on my thigh and i was like
like yeah you know i don't like this at
all
and she kept saying i'm like do you mind
just not bending over until i pass you
she's like oh that's okay and i was like
i just i can feel your butt cheek
spreading on my thigh
literally i think you said i couldn't
feel your body because she was looking
at me so weird i'm like
then your honor she said i can feel your
butt cheeks
spreading on my thigh and i said you've
bent over like four times and it feels
like you're not
you're kind of doing it to make space it
just seems there's not any space here
it's boxing you up yeah and she was like
well you
shouldn't have jumped up and got your
stuff you should have i was in the aisle
in front of you
and i said i would i tried to wait for
you you were sending an email and i'm
not your secretary so
i'm not gonna wait for you if you don't
jump up in it i don't know certainly
throwing the secretary because i
wouldn't i've never had people wait for
me to send an email
who's more of my wills doesn't wait
will's my secretary will come
late and he doesn't he don't wait for
nothing so then i said well i did i
looked i checked in with you you were
texting something while everyone's
getting up
so i stood up and then she was like
you're free to go in front of me i'm
like
i know i'm gonna do that and then i did
and then she said
[ __ ] [ __ ] when i pass her i was like
don't don't call me a [ __ ] she was
behind me this one i was like don't call
me a [ __ ]
you were being a [ __ ] first goodbye she
was like no i i didn't call you [ __ ]
i'm like okay
okay goodbye yeah you're you're also a
[ __ ] you're a butt spreading [ __ ] bye
and then i
your honor no stop stop putting me on a
record
well so then i walked out and you know
when they're like goodbye
she was like in front of as soon as we
got to the
uh the flight attendant she was like
this woman called me a [ __ ] you don't
act like that in our country
something like that and i was like oh
your country
didn't you just fly here from a
different country and then
this is a this is did she have a
american accent or
oh she's irish i just got it no i know
but you
she had a british accent no it's irish
the whole time god damn it it's just not
a good accent
okay so we came sorry my apologies we
came from another country and we landed
in
ireland and that's when she said she was
coming from america actually yeah
so that's when she made that comment and
then i just said to her
loudly i'm like you're a racist and she
was like
no i'm not i'm like you're racist that's
fine
you but don't try to get everyone on
your side because i'm not irish
that's weird like this has nothing to do
with behavior in someone's country
and then so when we were walking through
the um you know you have to do the long
walk to like
passport control the longest walk it was
long for her
i just i was i she was she eventually
got in front of me i'm like you're
racist by the way i
wouldn't stop you you wouldn't drop it i
said it pulled a nail
she was like all of a sudden she was
like leave me alone
i told you i didn't want to say and i
was like i just want you to know you're
racist at some point someone has to tell
you
what you said was racist i didn't like
what you said she was like
tell this lady to leave me alone i'm
like i'm not doing anything wrong you're
a racist
and then um and then she went down to
escalator
and then she looked back and i was like
you're racist and she was just
one girl by the way you know i was
saying that's
the kind of story i want you to tell
because it's got everything i need
pettiness victimness and racism
is there a chance tell me she would have
not said it if you were white well she
said can you
okay if i really try to remember she
said something like can you believe
this woman's this no something tanks
[ __ ]
no she said something like you don't
behave that way in our country
you have you we don't behave like
something like
if you you can behave that way in your
country you don't behave that way in our
country
she called me huh and you're filthy
ghetto
and then she like goes to the fine times
who are just like goodbye
can you believe she called me a [ __ ]
i'm like that was
i you know the undertone felt like nah
[ __ ] not in my
not not in my country right i don't know
but you called me
very xenophobic and not been racist yeah
but you know i wasn't going
to tell you why yeah why why be specific
when you can just blanket call somebody
a racist right everyone well if you
don't know them and they're being a dick
and you're already gonna be petty
it's like well why are we let's just
turn on all my petty
my penny points i don't know i would
like to solve the puzzle
you're a racist okay i have a question
yeah so when someone's in front of you
in a plane yeah do you you're no i'm not
you get
a 10 second grace period and then 10
seconds okay once
i did think i'm like well what how what
did you want me to do i waited
i thought i rethought about and when she
kept putting her butt on me it was like
the fourth time and
i was like this is a case of it
it would help women's interactions if
you were a little bit afraid of getting
popped in the face
that's the thing that keeps male
interactions in place
like that where it'll be like oh yeah
sorry man because we don't want to fight
we literally like you're like this is
two moves away from
it's one move away from fist fighting
right so we need to de-escalate it's
true
with women there's no it's all
any you're just like yeah well that's
why [ __ ] you're racist well you're a
[ __ ] foreigner
what happened here whereas a guy would
have been like all right cool man you
want to get by
cool right it was very like well
the thing is i actually thought she was
just that like a simpleton like your
butt is on me i don't know you lady and
it's the aisle so there's really not
that much room
and then when she said well you and
that's when i was like oh that was a
retaliation like we're hippos [ __ ]
in front of each other to like mark our
territory
yeah that sounds like yeah okay like i
can be petty too
please yeah um but i've also been in a
fight
and i don't know that recently
in my adult life all right i guess you
gotta tell the story i don't see it
absolutely no i'm not telling you but
the point is that
i that's behind the paywall if you want
to hear the
bianca go to our patreon patreon
7 to our page okay so no i i've been in
fight but i don't
like fighting i feel i felt terrible no
you didn't like it
no nobody liked it no there are dudes
there
there are girls and guys who are like
you want some
no there are yeah they're [ __ ] roid
heads like meathead
italian there's like yes you can
pick them out he likes fighting like
there are a certain group of people that
like fighting but most men don't don't
yeah no they don't want to fight i think
i just wanted i thought the moment i
said like hey man
like i just think i'm i'm a direct like
if we have a problem i'm going to be
oh no excuse me i was like i can feel
your butt cheek spreading on my thigh
like
that's uncomfortable for me would you
like to feel a guy's butt cheek
spreading on your eye
no no but i'd love to
feel the ladies behind the patreon wall
behind me i'll see you on patreon
um also i got the greatest vegan [ __ ]
i've ever had this weekend
a place called wolfies wait i want to go
i'm going to go after it's on new york
it's on york in highland park in l.a
which is a great neighborhood by the way
like i've never really been there
and i did a stand-up show there a couple
wait highland park
yeah i don't know like it's right next
to silverlake
no it's not okay it's it's eight minutes
from silver lake
no no no that it is because i drove to
silver lake
okay afterwards what route you took but
eight minutes
i don't know what time was it at night
time yeah during a [ __ ]
pandemic yes sure yeah so yes it's all
very good
it's not far from venice during pandemic
i see now you could date that girl that
lived
no it's still not worth it wait neil
dated
neil was like seeing us go on highland
park and
at some point it the the distance
just became totally i don't even bother
if i match with a girl in an app that
lives in silver like
it's literally like oh well this is
never gonna he's like it's
basically long distance it's yeah she
lives in oakland she's worth it fight
for her
[ __ ] out of here we got more letters we
got a bunch of letters like that coming
up
i got some my thoughts on marriage have
only gotten worse
okay um we also got some songs
it should just be the end but the guy
that's the guy who puts too much garbage
in
i know like like five what about five
sauces
barbecue sauce but what about teriyaki
mango no one wants oh yeah piece of [ __ ]
which song is this the kids kids on the
ukulele
oh yeah this is it's they're all theme
songs but what's the
what's the theme of it they're all just
theme songs they're all halloween
themes
how do you feel
[Music]
hey i like the spirit of it
it works across the board it's so good
structurally you can chop it up
what pinky tinky they [ __ ] it up they
were adorable
the children they're my they're my ghost
children
i'll never have them but no no thank you
for your songs children
oh my god they're so cute great there's
what's how would you describe this one
well uh trouble in the winner's circle
guy
theme song great
[Music]
cut to the exterior of my house right
beautiful you on the couch yeah hey hey
bianca um
ding-dong uh okay great next song please
what's the how would you just eric
johnson
feel harmonic yeah there were some
there's some like choral
some of these songs are unbelievable go
ahead please
that is like i don't know father of the
bride some like 90s
what like christmas themed yeah or it's
like uh
the omen uh one or the other
there's a better choral version i can't
believe someone out did eric johnson but
someone out did eric johnson
okay christopher bill outdid them
that's so good literally creeps me out
why because it it's like too
powerful it's amazing like don't do that
i love it no of course but it's
absolutely fantastic but it's just too
much it's
this if i were a narcissist i would love
that
i'd be like that's the perfect song
right there but as a just a selfish
person
it makes me uh a little uncomfortable
because it's too grandiose it's great
it's wonderful
bill christopher bill eric johnson can
you believe
eric johnson the five-time champion yeah
gets unseated only in the coral division
all the garbage songs are fantastic
um anyhow we're 23 minutes into a
podcast we haven't talked about the
earth
good job will well thank you buddy um
now is there another song it seemed like
there was
there's no way oh yeah it's too soon
it's sad
jimmy carr said that he almost cried
listening to my mom's rules today he
texted me
oh my mom was extremely
upset she was like sorry you're gonna
have love you got sorry he was shown no
love i was like
jimmy's like don't get me wrong i like
the results but
i got a bit choked up that's just how i
read his tweet his text
oh my god um that's so funny i like what
i'm seeing
um oh yes thank you
thank you i haven't even gotten to the
but we'll do a dump purchase it
later yeah okay let's talk about the
debates now
going into the debates i made a couple
predictions
you can but i as much as everyone thinks
he lost
that's exactly wrong no no that's
exactly what i thought he would do
biden didn't win biden only looked good
because trump looks so [ __ ] bad
neil that's not what you said you said
he's gonna win
the debate and you text me what was
happening he's winning he was winning
i'm still not convinced he didn't win no
he didn't win
because out this is how this is my
measure of knowledge yes so after
debates
i go on to all these conservative
websites and
subreddits and they were
having problems defending him there was
like i love trying a boyfriend i mean it
was kind of [ __ ] up like it was a lot
of like
high voices on the on the right like
our conservative i went on like it was
it was very hard no there wasn't a lot
of like great job
no i don't but my point was that
quiet looks bad
next to energy i get that but
he misplayed it in that
the over talking was he misplayed it and
like when biden talked i wasn't like
no right biden missed like so many
opportunities
brian missed all every opportunity he
could have been like that's a
750 dollar question like t i'm not even
talking about zingers because somebody
actually
texted a great singer or emailed a great
singer when trump asked biden how he was
going to come up with the 100 trillion
dollars
to finance his climate change policy if
biden
could have just said i'm going to make
mexico pay for it zinger
zing but we've already established that
these are you kind of do got to do
zingers
yes biden kind of
can't though meaning he's not a good
he he tried the problem biden is one of
these guys who's
trying to do like the spelling bee
version of answers and it's like dog
what's the answer you don't mean like
well you know one out of every
uh uh one out of every million
okay you got black people and then you
get a million of them
and then one of them's going to diet and
you're like dude you've just don't
say his handler should all keep him away
from
statistics stats and and like did you
know
i don't think the best was like he
doesn't have a plan the coronavirus
stuff when he could really finish a
thought i was like yeah
good enough yes it still wasn't good
which was
yes yeah no exactly so that's what i'm
saying like
biden didn't win trump didn't win either
no winners there there was a tie for
second but congratulations
you know that's when i was like this
really was
if we were really really wanted to be
trump
why wasn't there a younger person
besides a pudditate like footage i'm not
talking about
i'm like a young charming person could
have annihilated
trump where are the young charming
people that want to be president in the
democratic party
i mean they're where are they if you if
you become a politician
you're already disqualified you don't
your
any charisma you have is going to be
used for
personal gain there's no
incentive there's not people don't i i
can't think of anybody who wants to
like do it for the right reasons like
like
dave's stepbrother ben jealous ran for
governor maryland and lost but
he he wanted to do it for the right
reasons but
apparently the voters he wasn't
character i'm assuming he wasn't
character i don't know what happened
right
um to be charismatic to be all that
stuff
no one ever uses charisma for the right
reasons it's not
it's you know occasionally you'll get an
mlk mlk
in a weird way isn't that charismatic
he's pretty charismatic
but he's not like dripping with charisma
he's dripping with authenticity
and he's dripping with uh
christianity but he's not like i have to
[ __ ] him
to not like no but i i'm there's
different types of charisma you know
what i mean you could be
a nun and you know have no sex appeal no
none of that and still be really
charismatic and just powerful
i don't think it's impossible but there
are very few people that are charismatic
that don't go i can make a [ __ ]
zillion dollars out of this
why would i you have a little bit of
like uh
like when you go to like uh
i don't know a um like a theme park or a
carnival and you have a frontal line
pass yeah
or farther up in this line yes that's
what i
said a couple weeks ago it's the most
valuable
human resource you can possibly have
i'm now convinced it's not even close
charisma
so you've got joe biden who kind of used
to be charismatic he was a little
bumbling
there's a good front line by the way i
watched the front line the choice
2020. uh and it's mostly about their
uh their characters and it's a reminder
that everyone forgets
that trump the church trump used to go
to was norman vincent peale
the prosperity gospel it sounds like
some southern [ __ ] the guy's church was
in
manhattan okay and that was trump's home
church and the guy's whole thing
was about like think positively and all
that like
people always forget that they started
bringing it up again this week
because of the front line uh i heard it
on npr
um or the the daily the new york times
thing but uh
because i'm a total liberal example this
week does he talk like that normally
uh no they told him michael barbaro
the hmm thing they he did because he
wouldn't do anything
he wouldn't do anything and the producer
like you have to respond oh it was just
like dead air yeah
so now we're stuck with hmm but just
like
this weekend oh yeah that's just radio
[ __ ] okay
uh so
now the paul the polls
are are flat the poles i've heard about
since they're flat from the last week it
binds up a little bit right but he
didn't trump didn't get a bounce from
that you know that corona bounce that
everyone gets
yeah everyone's like he's like uh he's
he's like
the the british prime minister where
he's trying to do it
and then everyone rallied around him
it's like first of all you think these
things outside of eight-second intervals
the guy can't [ __ ] there's no
strategy
there's no strategy it's just what's the
thing that's going on right now yes
every moment what's the most
advantageous thing for me for me for me
for me for me
um
the the funny thing is to me
watching so it's all women that are
turning on him
that those are the people he's losing
yeah pole wise again i'll believe it
when i see it
uh it's like who did you think he was
right that's weird when people turn on
him it's like yeah
who did now you don't like him what part
of grabbing by the post
that was before the election it just
speaks to a weird
just a misogyny that that
that cannot be overstated well also the
misogyny doesn't only come from
men i mean women are no especially but
that's
and that's the i
was talking to somebody about my i'll be
long dead but
when different oppressed groups women
any might when when
either either the group gets power or
uh they just get enough people that
you'll see
that you have problems that have nothing
to do with
white men just human [ __ ]
impulses that like women in a
in a closed environment are weird with
women like
female relationships see also your
airplane ride
are very complicated and they're okay
they're very
that's two people out along with who got
stinky pits and feet
uh and back right yes and butt cracks
she's rubbing on her
eyes you don't mind if i masturbate
um i think that i it's some cave [ __ ]
honestly i i think it just is cave [ __ ]
i think
it's some queen bee [ __ ] it's some
women like [ __ ] a certain way and
they don't want another woman's impulse
uh input it's
it's the mother-in-law problem it's the
daughter problem
it's the it's just the problem it's the
mom-mom problem
it's i think women like
women weirdly in my experience i mean
they're known for like better
group dynamics yeah that's fine but
individually
it's not great you know what's weird
though i
i've almost rarely i have gotten in a
fight with
from woman to woman i have so few
problems with women whether it's friends
strangers i always try to like
at some point there's a line with anyone
where it's like okay i'm not a punk
so now we have a real problem but most
of the time i've
only gotten in arguments with men
strictly like even at work
any work any
any and every environment i've ever been
had like conflict with it's only been
men
and not women so i don't know i don't
see example that but i have a female
boss
i just yeah it's a female boss thing
it's a
it's just that women are
complicated additions to
things i don't think that people are
dying for kamala to be the president
honestly i don't think that i don't
think i think zero conservatives will be
i including women will be excited
if she has to become president and joe
biden if nothing
else looks incredibly healthy and uh
and i don't think
i think liberal women are cool with it
yeah i think liberal men are
fine with it but i was
i think hillary was way more qualified i
think she is qualified but
hillary was like wildly qualified yeah
he'll lose qualified
but it's not about quality but she
wasn't curious no it's not about
do you see that smile did you see that
song which one she's like
remember when she starts doing these
she's like if you learn about her
she's a [ __ ] interesting no i think
she's interesting
i just think it's funny when they tried
to make her more personal and it was
like
it's like no she's fine
yeah i don't want to see her smile with
kanye
yep but some people just don't have a
great smile isn't that so funny
how they're taking selfies with them and
then with trump
why is kanye west in like i don't i just
think it's
funny you could be so famous and somehow
you're
a stone's throw away from the president
why
there's always a weird relationship with
celebrities they want the reflective
glory each each way at a certain point
celebrities only want to spend time with
celebrities because
everyone else is beneath them
they'll never say that but they don't
they want to spend time with celebrities
because
it's it means they're still famous yeah
it's like a pr it's like getting your
your your
passport stamp like i'm still famous mr
president yes you are
kanye yes you are and then everybody
goes on um
hillary yeah hillary doesn't have a
great smile she's a little like
cock-eyed smile
so sorry lady now men
you know obama had a great smile yeah
bullish had a fine smile i i've never
thought about people's smiles
but she's clinton bill clinton's smile's
not great
his was great he looked like he was
having a great time
bush smile ooh not good it's not bitt's
cute look at that one
he's looking at ewok yeah
is that ellen yes how did alan get in
here
i stand by
thinking that hillary's more qualified
and there's no
reason why she
i think people will if if kamala becomes
president
i think no one's gonna apologize to
hillary but the problem is
hillary is more qualified than trump so
it's obviously not about qualifications
right my
keith is more qualified than trump in
her defense uh no
of course she was more qualified but
that's i was thinking today like the
stup
the the process is [ __ ] warped
where we should pick the president we
should literally
get a list of like a hundred people and
it should be like
some lady who works at the hospital and
some
people that are smart in whatever field
and we like surprise them with it
like the prize patrol like a publisher's
clearance yes
you get you're the president because
running for it
is you end up with trump and it's like
this can't
this can't be but the problem is like
okay if you look at other countries
their their political process mostly
three weeks it's like three weeks a
month yeah i don't know i just think
we we get so obsessed we're
into we believe our own hype america is
just like tv shows
now you're going to the hollywood you're
going to the dc round
hey you're going to dc oh my god i can't
believe it it's the reality show of it
yeah which is why homeboy won
like because he's [ __ ] the greatest
reality wrestling character of all time
but it's not surprising when you think
that arnold schwarzenegger won
the governor's seat of california by
saying like you're uh
like just stumb catchphrases people are
like he's
funny yeah right that's not
a reason to no but it happened even here
in california where we think we're so
[ __ ]
excited i don't think who thinks
california smart i don't know anyone
no i mean we think ourselves we think of
ourselves as very liberal and
speaking for yourself i don't i would
never literally
never say california smart i think like
there have been some decent leaders but
i don't
i don't think that that it's like we
what we do
we politically we pick the right people
no
pete what the [ __ ] is his name pete
williams [ __ ] pete davis some
[ __ ] white man white man pete white
um uh gray davis
holy [ __ ] what a white name um
so yeah so i
watching it i thought they need the
spatula they needed
the aggression that i still think
being aggressive i'll believe it when
the votes are in
i because i truly will because i don't
trust polls i don't trust
all i know is to use the stand-up
analogy
biden didn't kill and trump had a ton of
energy
he misused it he he completely
squandered it and
and was uh it he went
it was the work he went from being a
rich guy
for 40 years to being rich and powerful
and having to argue with somebody and if
there's one thing i know
rich powerful people don't want to argue
with anybody
they want to say it and they want that
to be the law
yeah and so that's what a lot of it was
like
this waiter's job right who was this
waiter
why are these waiters talking to me
that's literally
like what what what so he couldn't let
them finish without it like what
no i can cut you off i should legally be
able to cut you up trumps was like
biden didn't kill and trump
is like one of those sets where it
starts off okay and then it just
you lose the audience and you yeah you
gotta get them back so you double down
like let's say there's one weird
um interaction with an audience member
and then the energy kind of drops and
you
you double triple down and you
eventually bomb
i'd say he eventually here's what i'll
say to the same
it was the same way he was in 2016. it
was more cut-offs
it was crazier no of course but it
wasn't
there were more cut-offs but what i'm
saying is he said
awful [ __ ] to hillary the same way he
said to biden
it's just misogyny accepted it with
hillary
and with byron like that's a [ __ ] up
say about somebody's son
i think it was because we didn't know we
weren't used to it
it was more now fresh in our minds like
it was like oh what what is he doing and
he
he let her speak a little bit so he was
he could come in between
what she said like fuzz you know and
then it was it was it kind of
he volleyed with her he was in control
of like what she was saying
wrong and then when he agreed he'd be
like drew
like what do you don't cut her off to
agree yeah no we should
yeah it was better even though he did
say i'm gonna put you in jail yeah
you're right it was buried no it wasn't
he would seem so much more irritated he
was just out
he couldn't believe these [ __ ] waiter
why is this catty
and this waiter talking to me so it's
it's like he's outraged that they're
even
countering like what um
and now i have a controversial theory
about the proud boys thing
i look i think
um i'm a proud wife
uh i'm just proud to be a boy uh a bad
boy
i'm a proud bed boy um
i the thing of stand back and stand by
whatever the [ __ ] he said
i think he was just talking i really
don't think that was a call to
uh action i think it was like standoff
stan i think he was literally just like
stand over
stand down don't make an excuse for him
no no no the [ __ ] stand by doesn't it
the excuses i'm not
i don't i don't think he was telling
them
to maybe i'm naive i don't i
honestly don't think i think he was just
saying like stand
down stand through stan i think he was
just insane
adjectives the the
the comments or whatever a modifier
what's buy
what's down by something an
adverb it's not important
it's really not important no preposition
so um so the
what we said before was like you know
are you they because they're coming in
from out of town that was what they were
saying so are you gonna talk to them
because they are also
agitating uh the like protests and stuff
like that are you gonna tell them
are you gonna condemn them coming from
out of town and stirring up trouble
to that point he said stand down and
stand by it's like i don't think he said
it like that
he said stand down stand by he was kind
of like whatever kind of standing you
want play it
he didn't say stand by and stand by
okay you know what he didn't say it like
that play the video
are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists
and militia groups and to say that
they need to stand down and not add
to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what are
you doing what are you saying i'm
willing to do anything i want to see
peace then do it sir
say it do it say it do you want to call
him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white surprise
stand back and stand by but i'll tell
you what
i'll tell you what somebody's got to do
something about antifa and the left
just like stan i don't that's not does
that look like a guy who's
making a call to action stand back and i
don't think i'm
i don't think he's like blood fat boys
but but that's how people are taking but
he
couldn't condemn it and if you can't
condemn it he's just gonna like
floodly doesn't say anything
everything's flubbed but even i think it
was kellyanne conway said that
it would be it wouldn't be good for him
to condemn white supremacists because
they of course there's people i i
absolute white supremacist he's an
absolute piece of [ __ ]
i wouldn't put that in my top five
examples
i think that is a that was a speaking
error
and we're never going to agree on this
wait hold on what's the error
he was saying what would he be like
stand back and stand by
i think he was just like [ __ ] get did
i repudiate you
just like stand back and stand by i
think he was just trying not to say
anything
against them right people were saying
standby
meant be ready on my command
which i didn't i still don't read it as
that i don't i agree i don't think he's
saying
guys guys the problem is that because he
can't
even condemn them of course that when
you go and you say anything else
it just is a call to action in without
you
this is again speaks to a
the somehow he's different now
like well he won't condemn he said
mexicans they come here they're rapists
he said there's perfectly people
on both sides like you there's way
better examples the
the way he's known is from a class
actions
a a housing is like that's how he came
into the game that's his first album
is a [ __ ] housing discrimination suit
like that's his his [ __ ] ready to die
so i think now he must he's
waden can that's what he does right
i and the fact that people voted for him
before is
insane so now you're expecting like
if you still vote for him nothing's
changed was he more
he said the the uh the charlottesville
thing
in a press conference in his building he
didn't say it
to bob woodward he said it with the
cameras on
like so so now i think now this has got
to be final start it's like it's there's
no final straw with this guy
yeah it's it's all straws it's just a
[ __ ] it's a new
it's mcdonald's you push the thing and
one straw comes out
and it will never end and it is endless
but then you know what happened what he
caught the coronavirus
did i say last week i think i said the
thing about why
democrats are just plain are just taking
as long as they can right
no because they're just hoping someone
will die did i not say that
no oh i must have said it on the phone i
get
confused he did yeah what did you say
i said the reason why democrats are
using every procedure they can
is just so someone dies their
only reason their only no their only
recourse is
republicans die that's why i texted you
this is what i was talking about because
it's like
let's just take as long as we can and
then yeah
right i mean they all got sick
yeah well yeah they all they well they
all tested positive some got sick some
got
degrees of sick degrees of sickness but
it's like
chris christie kelly it's the senators
those are the ones you want
really you want the special half on the
senators
uh yeah like those are the guys that
yeah
and they're saying like it's the jim
jordan no jim jordan didn't get it
oh he was just in the thing he was there
i don't even know if he was at the amy
county very thing
um i mean it's [ __ ] up but they
snubbed him
he should have been there he's the
number one mascot
yeah so uh it doesn't doesn't matter
um yeah
you just gotta hope just take as long as
you can
that's why contra that's why uh business
business affairs is slow [ __ ] hoping
you die
yeah you know how much interest you get
on the amount of money these people pay
on
like if if uh if a company can hold the
money
for as long as they can don't [ __ ] oh
yeah
this is slime yeah hey we have a new we
need a new paycheck company we got a
thing
so right you switched to accounting
firms now we want to approve amy coney
barrett
just there's hey there you guys there's
a there's a close
there's a close there's a close-up party
apparently because he got sick that they
can't
they can't pass her through because but
this is debatable
uh this is they're it's harder it's
harder but then there's
the senator it's harder but again
there's hard and then there's like mitch
mcconnell like you can't
well okay they all have the quarantine
for two weeks yes which and they come
back
on october 19th and
democrats now have to do [ __ ] where
they're like no we don't feel
safe yeah they're going to do some [ __ ]
some conniving [ __ ] which fine
it's all conniving yes the whole thing's
you should the whole
body is conniving so
bless them wait it out see what happens
just like again i don't want people to
die
that's another i got i was arguing with
trayvon roy this week about
trayvon had some meme like we'll run
memes by each other like hey is this
[ __ ] up and
there were a few people trayvon was
didn't have him but
he sent us a meme where it was like if
trump died it was like
trump dies is good and i was
kind of a little scoldy i was like
you can't hope for someone to die even
like hitler
okay like you gotta
death to me is is like the one thing
that you cannot publicly wish on
somebody yeah no it's weird
and then there's a guy i want to say
no one leaves feeling good some of the
memes for me i'm like i don't know
i gotta i like my mom like i don't want
to wish
like i love all the i have so many
people in my life i want someone to wish
death upon that yeah i get really super
true villainy i get two superstitions
yeah it's just
it's mad villainy it's like ah i don't
i don't think that's good and roy so
sometimes it'll be like me and
me and roy are in our 40s trayvon's in
his 30s and trayvon's just woker than me
roy
and like is trayvon hot uh
i don't know um
but will i feel like very old where i'm
like nah brother
like you feel like we feel like let me
pull your coat here where
roy yeah where roy had to come with like
no that's bad juju
he literally wrote bad juju like no we
can't we don't do that
young blood like don't
you can't wish death upon somebody it's
too [ __ ]
severe and
uh someone keeps sending me they made a
joke and i was like oh lol like
not about him dying just like oh my god
he got corona
yeah i didn't say lol but it's in that
tone and so
he keeps sending me memes that one
aren't funny and two are like just
getting
worse like he's working the algorithm on
you or is it
more extreme i'm like well i don't like
i don't need these
sent to me you know and it's i will say
though
it is funny that there is now a debate
of it's not cool to wish death upon him
well people are like twitter well uh
twitter made a rule
uh where you can't openly wish death on
somebody i was like okay
you guys are a 12 year old platform so
this just this is the first time people
wish death on somebody
and all someone was making the point of
all things they do allow and
all the racist and most disgusting [ __ ]
they're allowed but it's like
death on a sick person nana you've gone
too that's
the side but i i'm on their side i'm on
the side but
why why stand like where is the line
well the
the my thing with with the whole
argument
is like not death on a sick person
but i mean that's what it is um it's
death
that's so trump i'm just looking at my
news updates trump left the hospital
yeah he was discharged and then the
white house has refused to accept
proposed fda guidelines that could delay
emergency vaccine approval until after
the election so they're basically going
like no
we we we we're not gonna wait it's like
it's five [ __ ] weeks dummies did you
get the vaccine
nope yeah well i think once you're sick
it's too it's too late
but also did you see the side effects
with those vaccines
[ __ ] that oh i saw today that there's
severe side effects for some of them
like
neurological disorders it like attacked
this lady's spine or something like that
my goodness i heard it was rubbing its
butt cheeks
it openly rubbing its butt cheeks the
the vaccine is openly rubbing its butt
cheeks on a lady's thigh
and you want to talk about side effects
um
so trump got the rona the great thing
about trump is
he's behaviorally
so insane that you can't even imagine
what he's going to do
you know what's going to be awful right
you know it will be awful
it'll be dumb one part down one part
awful
uh the when he ghost rode the whip
that was so stupid you know what i heard
that because
because the car is meant to uh survive
like yeah
they're all trapped it's the it's the
worst dramatically sealed
inside you're in a hazmat suit with him
yeah and you can't it the virus is
literally
can't escape through like events or a
window
it you're in it's a hazmat suit yeah
you're inside
it's like sleeping bubble boy and
there's eight of you
and you're but that's what i mean like
he's so
he's the he's like the michael jackson
jimi hendrix of [ __ ]
like what did you do yeah what the jimmy
hunter
you gotta hear this and marvin barry
it's marvin barry you gotta hear what
this [ __ ] did
um this is
also a
it's a case of
not all the the the
i call trump the the dave did a joke
where he said trump is like
he's a twitter troll as president yeah
i think he is the embodiment
of the comment section meaning
if i'm near you in the if i'm like
people will hit it me
on twitter and it's like oh you're
mistaking
proximity on this app for proximity
in intelligence talent whatever
and but that's what
the whole everything is now where i was
somebody i was listening to somebody
talk
who was like her job was like uh
barista whatever just like a whatever
not dumb but not like
[ __ ] how did you get that job and she
was talking about
chronovirus and it's like why would i
listen to you
over dr anthony fauci a guy who's
dedicated his life
to infectious diseases why do you think
your
opinion is as valuable as his yeah and
it's because
in the social media economy
her opinion is as valuable as his if it
can get likes
yeah it by the way it doesn't even have
to get likes it doesn't
likes will just turn the person into a
monster there if i'm
if i comment under a fouchy clip
well there i've done it right i'm as
powerful as fat i know as much about
infectious diseases as fouchy
the guy who who was roommates with aids
the guy who was like i mean like knows
more about in fact
like you can't people don't know how
big the difference is and i wish we'd
explore this more with blake when he was
here
the amount that they know about
basketball
the amount like carmelo professional
basketball players
carmelo anthony was on a j.j reddick
another basketball player's podcast
and hearing him talk about like phil
jackson's triangle
and jj just throwing and you're just
like
oh i don't know any of this they just
they just know
the backside pick that guy feeds the
basket then this guy and they're talking
about it
like the way i would talk about stand up
or
anything that they have a complete
facility with
and everyone thinks every basket
no basketball fan thinks that no no
in fact i asked blake about
something and uh about the clippers i
think
or a team and he just wrote back
like a paragraph
and i forwarded it to to rock and rock's
like jesus
he should coach and i was like he
doesn't want a coach
like carmelo anthony who doesn't seem
that bright
knows [ __ ] they just know it's their
business
and i wish one of them would
just go oh what happened in the game
okay so
r4 couldn't match their fi like just
just they could jargon no no
commentators know it
nobody knows it it's [ __ ] crazy and i
wish fauci
would do that but it would just bum
people out and be like oh man [ __ ]
n n1 and the r r
ratio and all it's just it's just
science [ __ ]
where why do science when i can be like
rand paul and try to own you
and so you just end up with a bunch of
people
in the white house who are like this
with everything
and it's rarely does something bite
somebody on the ass this clearly
he hasn't bit someone on the ass this
clearly since calan and schaub caught it
i like to think it was the same it was
the same
uh strain the same family um
like i was talking to someone who is a
professor in like african-american
studies and stuff like that and she was
saying
then i read an article afterwards and
it's so interesting the reason why
africa didn't get it
as bad is because during ebola they had
so
many resources in play and they had so
many um
they had just had so much set up already
that's same with a lot of asian
countries yeah
because of the bird flu and so it's like
that yeah so and then in latin america
even with
swine flu i don't know but i did hear
that people didn't get rid of their
pandemic uh you know they just folded it
into the existing pandemic
i mean i think some countries are
getting i mean brazil got pummeled
yeah but brazil in terms of government
is is
insane yeah disorganized it's it's the
tanks
trump
it's just always it gets more racist
with what it
it is a gold mine because we're sitting
there no we're saying the term they want
no they said call us the tanks you dirty
um yeah and that's when it's like dude
explain that one explain the fact that
africa we always look at africa
like sad there's always a fly on
someone's head and that they cannot get
off
so sad right but the africa is excelling
right now they are not
they are not i mean there's still like a
lot of the roads aren't paved
but they don't they don't have verona
i'm saying they don't pandemic is not
taking them out like it is
yes yeah it just makes you i just want
people
nobody that listens to this podcast but
i wonder do people realize like the
whole world got how could it come from
somehow the democrats
or how is it smart people
said i think it's i think it'll end once
the election comes
so 70 000 brazilians died
yeah because of the american election
right paris is shut down as of today
because of the american election but
it's people going like i know
i know what it it no you don't you can
just ex i was
i was arg this is another argument that
we i had with uh trayvon and
and i youngblooded trayvon we gotta have
a name for them
uh trayvon yeah
yeah it's the it's but i was
they were talking about oh i don't think
trump has it
that when people said that i'm like oh
dumb dumb yeah like so come on i
so i said to roy and trayvon i go fellas
what not a good sign what [ __ ] it's
it's a higher form of buddy um it's
buddy 2.0 he's never gotten filled
fellas what what percentage of
conspiracy theories
in our lifetimes came true just
i'll wait literally tell me which one
has borne out
i'll i'll spot you the tuskegee
experiments right
which didn't even come out when it was
happening it came out way later
most of them like most things that
people wonder about you know that
yeah like no you know what nobody said
about trump getting it
oh he must have stood close to a 5g
tower what the [ __ ]
happened to that conspiracy you [ __ ]
polluters
you noise pollution [ __ ] that
truly were talking it like they knew
like they knew that 5g yeah
somehow somehow was giving people a
a viral lung infection also from
internet infographics yes we have to
remember the source
the most trusted source of information
the amount of times i've gotten 5g
infographics i'm like yeah and i was
like i
have i i have 5g phone samsung
everyone's like oh my god like
it's not i don't what do you think is
happening
they think they they think that somehow
it's this it's i we've talked about
conspiracy on here before which is
it's a better way it's a form of
religion
it's it allows people to believe that
there's these great
very singular powers at play it's the
bilderbergs or many of these people
and it gives them it feels safe whether
you realize it or not it's like oh
in bilderberg's we trust or like right
it's like a god but
they're corrupt somehow as if they need
to be corrupt these [ __ ] bilderbergs
if you have a billion dollars you're
making uh
if you have a billion dollars you're
making so much money and interest every
year you know it's like
you couldn't even spend the [ __ ] yeah or
bill gates is trying to in fact
the [ __ ] are you talking about dude the
[ __ ] are you talking that [ __ ]
cleared africa of malaria like
so what are you saying what i don't get
is
we i feel like and you probably have
friends that look at the
q anon and all the conspiracy theories
that come from the right
and say yeah can you believe it those
guys are [ __ ] idiots and then they're
like i don't think he has it yeah like
wait
yeah guys can't only be yeah idiotic
when it's
uh someone else that we don't agree with
politically or you know
it's all idiotic i as i always say
you don't need conspiracies when
lobbyists can write legislation
yeah full stop you just it's it's
so infuriating especially when people
that i
like somebody on the texans it was like
so you didn't [ __ ] with um
uh what was the 911 one like the big one
911 said seal beams
no like there was a movie loose change
so you didn't [ __ ] with loose is that a
like it was like a hundred million
zeitgeist yeah it was zeitgeist
basically it was like a zeitgeist loose
change
and uh and i told you i felt i was
susceptible i
that i never i just no i mean when i
i think i talked about in the podcast
but when i um
i saw the the one about the sandy hook
and then i was like
what no no
what the [ __ ] that and then i did it i
felt
weird because i was like oh i'm really
aligning myself with like a lot of like
nra people right now then i
did a quick google search of all the
information and it was all wrong
oh it was all it was all directly
developable but
in that moment when i see this i'm just
like
it's not we can call them stupid but
if you're only getting your source from
this one form
it's not i mean you're just believing
something
kind of convincing in front of you you
know right but you know who never talked
about conspiracies
rich powerful people yeah of course not
because they know
how the [ __ ] world works i'm just
saying that like i can under
it no it's because they don't they got a
cover-up no
no they don't that's nice they sure
don't know and i'm really embarrassed to
admit that but
it was all of what i watched a few clips
i'm like shut the [ __ ] up that sounds
funny yeah
then i googled it and i'm like and it's
but no one does that second step
everything wait a minute right and my
friends will send me pandemic they send
me these
uh literally it said bill and melinda
gates foundation and
someone photoshopped like like research
and human cloning
bill and melinda gates foundation of
cloning here and they were like look at
this sign
i said this initially bill gates could
[ __ ] up your life
so much worse than kovid yeah seriously
with
just go he just has to go to microsoft
and go hey guys give me a minute
in the big room with all the [ __ ] in it
i'll just put it on the lip
he could make all this [ __ ] he could
make this catch on fire right now if he
wanted to
this isn't even this is apple there's an
iphone but they respect him
that much tim cook respects him
that much that he would go how many
phones do you need to blow up that's it
it's scary it's scary that it's it's
just so
i don't know no one believes you because
if you sit there
and if you're just like you don't you
don't get it man
yeah it's a way for dumb people to turn
the tables on smart people like oh you
think it's
a viral infection involving
microbes do you dr fauci you
you suck ouchy you said simple man
somebody was saying like well they're
just gonna keep california closed
why do you think they'd wanna keep it cl
what [ __ ] advantage there to keeping
a
economy shut who benefits from this
bezos fine he's not involved in the
legislation he doesn't in he's not
involved in in decisions that are made
on a county-by-county basis of states
but it it gives dumb people a way to a
feel sorry for themselves which is the
best
and b turn the table on actual smart
people
and and make it seem like that they're
naive and full of [ __ ]
what with their education and knowledge
um how many people that you know of like
close or not that are a
um like a conspiracy right now like
anti-corona
you know what's funny is has anybody
surprised you roy i og
roy like three years ago he goes the
guiltiest i've ever felt in my life
was roy was trying to lose weight and uh
and he had like some blood sugar [ __ ]
and
and i walked in i walked in on i just
saw him at the daily show
drinking a coke and i go damn right
i thought you knew better and walked
away
uh people don't people don't
really hit me with not hit you but like
have you seen some like
as anybody you you're surprised by
i mean dave's a conspiracy person
dave doesn't count right uh you know
what i mean by that i just
is there someone you're like oh weird i
believe in
i believe in i do the the only and i
don't believe in
conspiracies redlining wasn't a
conspiracy
like i believe in racist legislation
wait what do you mean it wasn't a
conspiracy it wasn't a conspiracy it
wasn't
it was a law but there was a lot that it
was a it was a
it was a costume it was the norm it was
a law that i that's [ __ ]
rampant that i absolutely believe in
like did the fbi kill [ __ ]
uh fred hampton yes like they're [ __ ]
that's just demonstrably provable
but these worldwide global elite
the [ __ ] are you talking about they
couldn't america didn't wouldn't join
the kyoto protocol they wouldn't
they they won't condemn israel [ __ ]
by the way israel is getting shut down
protests
um because they israel's had like a bad
resurgence
is israel's not doing good in chronology
yeah and they had
they so they had a locked and now
they're having lockdown protests a lot
protests against against the lockdown
be and uh because it turns out israelis
didn't like being locked down to which
um palestinians said you're kidding
um what the [ __ ] you gotta be kidding we
thought it was just
us but i know it's different um
so yeah there's no like the u.n
the the united states won't condemn
there's just all these [ __ ]
side deals that prevent
an illumina that prevent a global
anything
like bolsonaro and uh duterte
and [ __ ] kim jong-un
and erdogan aren't entering into
global conspiracies with america in the
uk
[ __ ] give [ __ ] yourself right [ __ ]
yourself and
saudi arabia and ua i mean just it's
anyone who says it hasn't thought it
through it's a lot more
business and money related than it is
it's all money come on guys
yeah it's all money related you're gonna
[ __ ] everyone up yeah and if somebody
has to hire somebody or any of that [ __ ]
it's because it's like
i gotta do my buddy a favor yeah it's
not like i shall
plant him and this is
and then there's political [ __ ] like the
supreme court and
uh and mitch mcconnell and
[ __ ] with like clarence thomas it's like
there are revenge plots ongoing
but none of this is lasting like it is a
brotherhood with a sword and we shall
right well that's no smart person
whatever
whatever i think the problem is there
are the conspiracies that really make it
mainstream are
they're such theater they're so they
have all the elements
like pizza a pizza shop and you don't
realize
and it was on this list and blah blah
blah and
now we have to worry about the children
i mean also
it has every element for a good
you know like but they're not well
written i mean they're not
they're not well again and but i mean
you know i watch reality tv i'm not
proud to admit that
it's not but you know that they're no
it's not skulls
right that they're all borderline brain
damage
but some people yeah at best the best of
them are
our brain damage but these people like
with pizzagate they
it becomes by their identity people we
know of course and it's like
pizzagate and and if somebody believes
[ __ ] like this
i can assure you of two things they're
not smart
and they've they are not powerful and
they've never been powerful and they've
never been around
a powerful person because you know what
powerful people are
stressed all the time and they're not
stressed because
the illuminati's over the shoulder so
they're stressed because they have a lot
of
[ __ ] they have to do and it's they're
not
it's not they're not stressed because
they're trying to arrange
uh a molestation
they have [ __ ] paperwork
we can't find any hot kids i've never
met a a
powerful person that was stressed out
beyond a thing that would stress a
person out
the funny thing is there are legitimate
conspiracies about child molestation
rings there are legitimate ones
it's not pizzagate you know and that's
for me like if you really care if you
really care and it isn't politically
motivated
and it isn't just some nonsense by some
dude living in the philippines
i mean that's where this whole thing
comes from
uh i came from podesta's emails and
mentioning having a a a
party no no so the people who run
channel where
they came from yeah are they like even
they were like this is too much they
were like this is dude but that even
that guy's like
kind of has some weird child molestation
charges in in the philippines he can't
go back to
you know i don't stay in the philippines
or thailand for more than a week because
i don't feel like i don't just i don't
but i just don't want any
like no i don't want it on my passport
my irish passport dirty up that irish
um but no so for me i'm like okay if you
care about the children there are so
many things you can get behind there's
so many things you can bring
light to there's so many organizations
that need attention
none of them vacuum just give money to
rain rape and incest survivors
none of them back humanon none of them
none of them are like yes
you're it's nonsense so somebody i just
i
liberal podcast mentioned that
um that
one of my podcasts is just a liberal man
giving a liberal woman a massage
it's just oh that's good that's a real
podcast no
oh no it's a joke podcast that i made
sorry like
[Music]
he said that they they work stuff like q
m works because it's
it's it's like a online game
that people can kind it's like a puzzle
larping type game where all the rules
apply like
after a while it writes itself you just
have to create this world
and then and then it like just just like
the
the the amount of amount of people
involved just
will spread it for you it's funny you
know i like my spooky stuff and
sometimes i go online and i read spooky
stories
and so but there's this one
website they go on and it's weird
because the stories are clearly they're
just made up stories
i'm in a hotel in in the philippines or
in vietnam or something like that
and um you know there's a little girl in
the hallway and we checked now she's
knocking on our door
um the lights keep flip flickering you
know just something like that
all the comments are like call this is a
number everyone's buying into it yeah
and that part
is so weird to me cause i'm like guys
these are clearly completely made up of
course
everyone knows i thought it was fiction
that we were all into the fiction
and the comments are advice people like
thank you guys so much for the support
i'm like
what's happening what's happening this
is fake there's no little girl in a
hallway
how i i don't i don't i've never done
anything or been anywhere i live
in [ __ ] mississippi and and then
the the problem it creates is if i
reject it
it's like this is stupid right but then
i would call what if it's real
it's like there are plenty of american
kids getting molested i bet there's
plenty of american
human trafficking there's plenty of
[ __ ] help corey haim had a whole
movie about it
yeah no one wants to watch it or talk
right no one can
be like oh no man it's got is is uh is
there a pizza place
involved then i'm down there's childhood
station that goes on this city
there's town in hollywood and not like
on some hollywood elite just no
piece of [ __ ] people garbage people who
[Music]
i'm assuming there's some statistical
number it's a ver
it's a sexual attract it's like there's
a certain amount of straight people gay
people
people that like [ __ ] animals people
like it and choke people like of the
kinks
i'm assuming there's just a statistical
amount of those people
and you just gotta
find them and i and and do like raids
and [ __ ]
hard drives okay this is all the [ __ ]
yeah but but it's not going to happen on
a thread
on an 8-chan thread getting behind it
like yeah
cute like somebody you guys know this is
somebody did have a very funny tweet
which was uh
kellyanne conway's daughter's uh
tick tock is the number one news source
in america
uh which is very very funny um
you didn't watch american murder yet uh
um i know the story already in great
detail so
i'm wondering is it just a well laid out
or yeah i didn't know the story okay um
sick sicko oh you already saw the whole
thing i don't think he's not even sick
i've tried to explain this to people but
he of course yes of course he's sick
to sit there and choke her oh sorry are
you at that part
is it one thing yeah i mean it's for uh
no it's one episode
i thought it was going to be episodic
and then i was like wait i'm going to
finish this tonight
no i'm ready yeah i don't want to give
first i don't want to give her
so yeah the fact that he just
was like yeah i gotta get rid of her now
just
here's what i've said i've been saying
this for 15 years
there are we'll play if we only had a
song
play if we only had a song but we need a
song
three beats light as always um there's
one thing we can count on
it's funny i know it's funny um
and i am a [ __ ] so it was
don't be yourself and uh it's like when
you told me to stop fat shaming because
of kindness mike who said i was kind
um kindness i don't even spell it um
uh again that he that would have been
very funny ten seconds ago hey [ __ ] you
man here we go finally great now we're
talking
um there are men
who i've said on this podcast before
men [ __ ] up more lives thinking they can
be
decent than almost anything
any other uh definitely any other group
on earth okay
promising women that they can change and
be better
is a recipe for men to [ __ ] up a life
and that guy
wanted he wanted to be a dad yeah he
wanted to be uh uh and that lady there's
text from that lady's a [ __ ]
pain in the ass the lady the wife uh i
don't know what happened to her but she
she's a real pain in the ass she
actually said the night before like i'm
really sorry
uh that i was a pain in the ass because
they were going through some
yeah she said she was she's bossy right
her friend said she was bossy
and he just kind of was like cool with
it
and uh and then he
met she went out of town he met another
lady and he realized like oh
this is way better than that and
this is to my point there are men
who would rather kill their wives than
make her cry
oh no no don't put the make her cry part
in there
absolutely no it's not about them or or
their feelings go before uh the same
people that came to their wedding
and say hey i'm a piece of [ __ ]
that they don't have the courage to just
deal with this shitty situation
so they'd rather kill her i still think
other than the the kids i still think
he probably feels like well i don't have
to face him as much
here in prison i i promise you that's
one of his thoughts
i no don't promise that um i want take
the promise
no no i think it's funny because
sometimes my friends will date guys
and if i get i'm there's one friend of
mine who dated a guy
and i was like he's the type of guy that
would rather
kill you than face the shame of people
he's a
liar in the head he can't handle
that they're statistically scary i'm not
gonna say i'll go one in ten guys like
that
oh and i can spot them i it's the the
funny thing is when you said that
it's an active thought i've had of men
i'm just like you would rather kill me
not yes but they present
they're so they're it's the the outward
appearance the
yeah the the the kind of like i don't
know have you ever met like a kid that
would
you know when you're a kid you'd just
rather lie than deal with the [ __ ]
when they're just like just tell me just
be honest with me
no there's good tape from the confession
room that's the if you haven't seen that
that's it's some of the best tape i've
seen the shot's not good but
his confession is great the when you
watch
it and you see him like pleading
um not pleading he wasn't he wasn't
really pleading to the
news cameras of saying like they have
footage from
it's like they have cop camp somehow the
cops
cameras worked i don't know what
happened okay you know i think black
people might
jam the signal the melanin just yeah i
think the melanin jams it
you're too black for this camera um
so they have body camera they have body
cam they have a lot
is he just like i don't know where they
are i've never seen the guy and i'm like
this guy's
[ __ ] absolutely like no what is it
like
it's like uh uh
yeah oh i found her phone it's just
all pre-med would you look at that yes
like oh i found her wedding ring
i just i mean i just wish she'd come
home uh
turns her phone on as he's turning on he
goes like this thing's about to
uh blow up by about with phone calls
meanwhile
four of them are from him right like
just obvious
just incredibly odd then they go to the
neighbor's house to talk to the neighbor
and the guy the dad
guy the main guy i don't want to say
we'll call him the murderer
hypothetically
uh walks out of the the neighbor's house
and the neighbors there with the cop and
the neighbors like he's acting [ __ ]
crazy
yeah that's the craziest part the
neighbor's like
yo i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
yeah but
we're all i think the cops felt like
something was up of course
disappearance it's like wife and kids
and and kids
yeah like and she left her phone
she's dead that's it
if you leave your phone you're dead yeah
know that if you find my phone somewhere
i'm dead this is how stupid certain men
are though
i mean the fact that you think meeting
another woman
the the idea of like now this is nice
and easy
yeah because you're you're just you're
just [ __ ] mad are you
ding-dong she could be worse yes easily
of course
so and then you'd have to murder her
also
um
what do you i want to get into how those
types of guy present
because i think they present well i'm
thinking of one in particular like this
in particular my charisma class where
it's like
bianca really nice to meet you i've
heard a lot about you
i want to i want to catch up with you so
they're all they're all
charismatic but um there's cracks in
there
yeah yeah it's weird like um so my
friends rip off i'm like with me
so yeah where's your paper of people's
names
matilda um so
[Music]
so he i'll tell a little bit i hope he
doesn't listen to this because he
actually kind of scares me
but he started lying
very early on about complete
completely unknocking like completely
innocuous things that he had a boat
um that by the way i had the thought
they love boats these people
everybody has a boat that's a con man um
that his uncle was rich
his uncle that lives in texas why do i
care
i mean that's what you want to say to
this guy like why are you telling me
this um
and then his mom i really hope he's not
listening to this somehow
he's never going to but just he knows
does he know you know he's
why well yeah but uh not about these
things
it doesn't matter he's not going to
listen to this yeah so
his mom and my friend were talking what
if he's a huge fan
he's a really those people are also real
narcissists of course so
i don't think he'd listen to it to our
podcast of someone else being a
selfish person um so
his mom and him and her were talking
once and she was like he has a problem
and she said that when he was in
first grade he didn't do his homework or
he got in trouble
and he told the teacher i'm so sorry
like can you please
you know for excuse it i already love
the reasoning
my my parents are getting a divorce
they were not they were not they didn't
even know he understood what divorce was
and the teacher was like you know we
don't he doesn't have to do that
turn in that assignment i know i
understand you guys are going through a
hard time and she was like what
are you talking about your husband's
cheating on you your son told me and
uh i remember my friend was saying that
her mom
always thought i can't that was the
moment that like struck me about my son
why would he make something up so crazy
to get out of such a small issue
and i've seen him do that he completely
cheated on my friend
and it's the stories were wild i mean
these are weird stories here
i always call him dear john i don't know
if you ever watch that yeah he reminds
me of that but
i told her once i'm like he's the type
of guy because he would never leave her
alone just
you know disappear for six months always
phone call always an email oh if he was
blocked on everything
a letter like weird has another
girlfriend still hitting her up
he had like five he just he's a lot
right
and i told her i said you know he's the
type of guy that will kill you
instead of facing your friends
yeah be like we we're getting a divorce
and that's another case
of people thinking like that [ __ ]
hard can murder
be what do you mean get rid of a body
yeah smart i'm really smart really smart
i'm smarter than doctor fought i know
more than scientists about science some
q
on [ __ ] figure out yeah what dude you
wrap it in heart
i can bring down a worldwide child sex
conspiracy ring yeah so let's do a march
i'm murdering a [ __ ] i'm murdering you
tomorrow best part is
like a true man he had sex with the
night before
i don't know if you knew that oh yeah
yeah
why not sicko i
but i get it okay
but i but it is that thing of like just
stop
acting like you're good running they're
running for office
they're all running yeah stop it what
are you gonna get from this
right they get kids well but what do you
think okay let's go into the mind of
this man
what is the point of appearing
so good like what in them is so brittle
that they can't handle
appearing bad or maybe
men don't realize that we should not say
men this is a no it's this is a guy it's
a it's i think men are
all the man i don't think most men don't
murder the lady
okay this is a man problem go ahead
thousands do
most women who are murdered are murdered
by a man of course so
of course well who else is going to
murder women don't have the strength
women don't have the strength to
overpower them um okay now
yes yes please cut that up um
and use it against me um
guys don't realize that you can be
honest
and it's
it stings at first it's an uncomfortable
10 minutes or
an uncomfortable 10 years so just
take the 10 minutes and go hey
i don't think i think you're great
whatever i don't
want to have kids whatever like he
should have told her before
he cheated on her just be
straightforward or
tell her 10 years before and be like i
don't think
you're great and i want i want to
i want the guys often get into like
the kind of person i want to be because
i want to be a good man you make me a
better man all that [ __ ]
that mamma ganda uh
where it's like i she's brought out the
best in
just no well i mean when i was younger i
had a real hard time rejecting
it's hard for me even now if a guy is
very nice i'm like
like i can't be like hey i'm not
attracted to you i can't
it's very hard to do that especially if
someone's giving you love and attention
and affection it's very hard to stop it
and be like i want to get off the bus
the life yeah
it's i yes and it's hard to get up i
think it's hard to get off a love bus
and i think it's hard for
uh women to
you don't wanna it's it's that thing of
like you may kill us but i don't think
it's exactly
that i think you me the man woke up
women are afraid of being murdered by
men right
um but it's more
don't want to be the kind you don't want
to be kind of a
jerk in the you want to keep your
options open
well i really don't feel like most guys
have a pr most guys
are really honest i am not looking for
something serious most guys don't want
to
get into something when they're not into
it the next time but the next time you
bring it up
they'll it their answer will be softer
because they
now they've slept with you and they
don't
want to be there the answer gets grayer
the more like you know it's funny
just accept them at their word yeah just
that whatever you said at the top that's
the truth
it's like that i don't believe anything
women say sexually
or because i don't think
we've talked about it like i don't
believe anything a woman says about my
penis
i just will never believe them what do
they say
they're complimentary but i don't even i
don't even like
saying that on the podcast cause i don't
want people to think
that i think well of my penis no but i
don't want people to
i just go thank you i
you're not a good you're not a reliable
source
because women are trained like marines
to say it's great
that's great now that is true i have
lied
oh yeah
i don't think you're a liar i think this
is a scenario
where you cannot tell me the truth so
when you do
even though they probably are that's not
that's
so funny i've lied to every single
person i've ever slept with i'm sure
not even even if it was a true it's
still like i'm on autopilot
you don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
saying i'm like great it's great yeah
lovely size fantastic perfect meanwhile
there's only one that was
like i o that is my top through one
person by the way
one of your ex's who listens to this
thinks he's it oh no i never dated that
guy
so it wasn't you so you just saw a
picture of it
no i never dated him wow
it was okay all right entanglement
situation
uh but no i just it's funny cause
because when you're hanging out with
that person
it does become the like it's the soup of
the day it's great
yeah but i do like i think it's rude
i think it's r it would be rude to say
a little below average it would be root
the same way it's kind of like
women i don't trust a thing women say
about my penis and women
shouldn't trust a thing men say about
their relationship
yeah like we can't i don't know though
guys are pretty good at that
age-old rule of if you have nothing nice
to say don't say something else
guys don't just give out fake
compliments
no they don't no neil neil's making a
silly face with his glasses check my
phone no
no no no he doesn't
no okay so no guy's going to be like
damn you're [ __ ]
first of all [ __ ] compliment is insane
because they're
all they're all great compliments
they truly are it's like it's a thing
it's not even no guy's not gonna say
like you have nice hair
if you have shitty hair don't do the
like
fake out from zero compliment
from nothing who was who was talking
they'll find something that
guys complimenting the thing about you
that they don't like
going like i like your oh what taylor
thomas and i started to stand up and she
was like guys will come with the thing
that
they know you're insecure about be like
i like your eyebrows you're like
why did you mention them right why did
you bring that but that's when people
tell you like you know i don't find
crystalline
yeah exactly exactly yeah just stop it
it's fine i don't think you should trust
what any guide says about a relationship
i don't even think you should trust
i don't think with guys i don't think
you trust their word or
most of their actions you can't trust
anything a guy says about relationships
they're just not reliable that guy want
because there's too much
incentive to be
normal be a great guy be one of the good
guys be a [ __ ] he's a good guy he's
again
they're also yeah they're kind of like
you know toddlers when you're like be
honest
who spilled it it's like they don't want
to be honest
being honest is not scary bottom line
yeah get your [ __ ] ass whooped
yeah when you're a toddler you get your
ass up and when you're an adult
man and you say what you actually think
about a relationship
you're gonna get your your sex
privileges revoked that's men's
biggest fear yeah if that dictates ever
that's why as i've said on here before
that's why men won't
that's why men don't talk about sexual
conquest experience very much because we
don't want it getting back to her and
then she won't have sex with me
so she's like yeah what right we just
won't talk about it
but that's that's why guys try to break
up in a nice way that's why guys will
reach out
just checking in making sure you're good
just thinking about you this being
october they just constantly like i'm a
good guy right
yeah sexually sexually a candidate
still a sexual candidate st that's all
they want to be
it's a sexual candidate yeah uh
so at best they lie at worst
they will murder you
[Music]
hey wonderful humans first of all love
the show
thank you for your openness and honesty
i am a trauma therapist in las vegas and
found neil from three mics didn't we all
it's such a gift to be able to share
with my clients so number one can we get
an update on your depression
i'm sure you have talked about it on one
or more of the pockets but i haven't
listened to it
uh like for example still on meds tried
anything new
how are you feeling with it now number
two have you done emdr eye movement
desensitization and reprocessing
uh if so can you share your experience
uh yes i've done
right now i'm on nothing
i'm [ __ ] raw dogging this thing okay
the reason i'm raw dogging
to do the ayahuasca yes it's because i'm
supposed to do ayahuasca and you can't
take
you can't be on nissri so last week and
a half i've been
i was titrating for two weeks and then
i'm
now i'm done but isn't that a little
i mean the risk is that you can get
you get serotonin syndrome like you get
too much serotonin which
i i could would bet money will not
happen to me what even honest
you can die if you take ayahuasca on and
you
and on you take an ssri you can die
it's like one person a year probably but
don't be that one person
what are the odds come on let's do this
so i have no idea no i quit
yeah so i've been no what are the risks
of not
taking your ssri medication oh uh like
can't you
maybe fall into like a terrible dark
depression
my track with all this stuff is
so [ __ ] up but
i did the tms in china
in december or november last year that
helped a lot that was good and i
may not need ssris
so i don't i may not even need them i
the reason i went back on them is
because i was having panic attacks
really i had anxiety i had panic attacks
like the whole week leading up to three
months i thought i was gonna have a
panic attack
when i did that i literally that's
healthy
the night before three mikes jessie nick
was sp
spade or justin nick was supposed to
bring me up and i was like
couldn't go on have you ever had a panic
attack go inside i've never had a panic
attack
i had them that week the reason i had
them this it's too long a story
i took human growth hormone because i
was like
[ __ ] it yeah and that hype
like amped my system i got them from a
[ __ ]
and that it was like a whatever i'm sure
right now someone's like you know i have
good ship
it's fine what does it do hgh yeah the
funny thing about hdh because i ended up
giving it to bijan
uh it makes you it makes it makes you
like
more aggressive at four-way stops like
there were little things where i could
see myself
being aggressive proved his vision is
that true that i've heard that too
yeah it's it's good [ __ ] is it it's
human growth hormone it's a thing that
your body stops creating after a certain
age or just
diminishes and it just gets it up to 20
or a level
what um what are the side effects just
more in my case
panic attacks [ __ ] that and
it was and then i had anxiety for three
months
i'd never had [ __ ] anxiety not worth
it or was it
no not worth it but i don't even think i
was on the right it's a long story i got
it like
bootleg tijuana dumb
the dumbest way you can do it uh
so that came in panic attacks
then i had one in england
what happens when you have a panic
attack what do you do i like can barely
speak
on stage so
like my throat's choking i can't
and and having anxiety like for three
months sucked
because it feels like you're getting a
little
like a little taste all the time yeah
like a little taste
it's like your brain keeps reminding you
you're just constantly like oh [ __ ]
like you're just you can't chill so what
happened
when you were done with the anxiety did
you have like i never
got done with it i just went back on
zoloft
yeah that's all i got it i just don't
have anxiety anymore
okay so this time that was
three years ago so i've been on zola for
three years
stopping it for uh
ayahuasca went on stage
a week ago it was like one of these
parking lot shows
and i you have to like get on the bed of
a truck and it's like this
it's very and i started to get a little
panicky
why because
i don't know because you're not supposed
to speak in front of people
right like your body is not like [ __ ]
yeah your body's like what the f
we don't [ __ ] this so
but whatever i got through it and it was
like 20 seconds of like
so but it was i would have been nervous
anyway because it's
you're get you're climbing up onto an
unstable thing in front of a hundred
people
it's like a recipe for falling so
so now i'm on nothing i'm gonna do
ayahuasca
probably go back i'm just start back up
on it uh
and i have done emdr emdr is very good
that was a big help i did like two years
ago
uh big help
with trauma i mean that's such an
overused word but
the the part that's interesting is the
the
reprocessing thing you basically there's
it it doesn't what doesn't make sense
like on paper at all
it's by hemispheric tapping in your
hands
like there's a you hold like an
electronic little paddle like a like one
of those like a tiny version of the
cheesecake factory your tables ready
thing
and just boom boom boom boom boom boom
does something your brain so each side
of your brain's getting activated by the
taps
you you re
kind of live a
traumatic episode probably violent
whether it's car accident whether it's a
and you re you basically just rewrite
it's like the way you could write over
your brain uh cds
in the 2000s that's what you're doing
for your brain
for experiences so it's really good as
she said with
with front line uh
soldiers it's really helpful but how do
you know which
one it re tapes over uh because you
go you re you with a therapist you talk
about
the thing and you go but like this time
i'm stopping it
oh that's great yeah it's great yeah and
it works really
it works so well so this is how like
small world crazy so
jamila the the host of the misery index
on tbs
everybody over there i'm in the good
place um
she she saw three mics got my number
got my email from mike shurer who
created the good place i used to write
with
i didn't know her at all she was like
you don't know me
you have to do this therapy i do the
therapy
really helpful she does another podcast
she does um
russell brand's podcast um
and bijan hears it
doesn't know i know her and goes i want
to do this
bijan's gonna become an emdr therapist
oh my god
really yes he's like doing it now
he's doing like his own kind of homemade
emdr
with like vr goggles and [ __ ] like he's
he's inventing his own methods
um it's really helpful just like retapes
people's friends over with
images
um with grand theft auto missions your
dad didn't hit you
you stole that that animated car
um so
emdr is great and i recommend it to
everybody it doesn't make sense
just try it that's all i always say
everybody or people
anyone with uh i don't think it would
hurt anybody okay cool but if you have
a traumatic thing yeah or even if it's
emotionally traumatic
it can i i can tell you
it's very hard to say
when something is like i am x better as
a result of that i would say i'm 25
emotionally healthy as a result of that
so it i don't think it's gonna like
get me married or anything you know
let's not be crazy
but goodbye you've got mail what's up
y'all og feeler second time caller
r-e-s-p-c-k i've been thinking about how
white people collectively have barely
scratched the surface in terms of
acknowledging racism racial prejudices
i know this because they haven't
classified it into dozens of categories
and subgenres
almost every other thing or experience
has been studied to the point
where different parts of it are labeled
based on characteristics
except racist people just get a generic
racist label slapped on them and then
they're dismissed
we need to establish a nuanced
classification system when describing
racist behavior
something similar to how liquid wine are
placed in distinct categories
based on certain characteristics like
vintage geography or flavor profile
how neal feel and what big rig banks
thinks
hey what do you say big rig banks
i like it i mean it is we do have
anti-semitism
yeah and it's funny because everyone
no one's ever like
was it really anti-semitic was it or
were you just being a little sensitive
we probably didn't mean it like that
right we're all very yup that's [ __ ]
up
because you know jewish people have been
persecuted for a very long time
but i don't know why we aren't that
supportive when it comes to i i know why
because people don't like people without
white skin on them covered in white skin
uh yeah i mean i guess my question would
be
to what end but be because it's a
word for it like
for anti-black racism okay
i mean i think when people say racism
they think
white on black yeah
you know i don't what i'd be more
concerned about is the laws
before the words and the labels
stan by the way if you're a proud boy
stan stand by
um uh stand stand stand through and
stand down
um i think just
get i i again far be it for me to go
like hey you're focusing on the wrong
thing but
it seems like the bigger issue is not
the way it's presented
it's just that [ __ ] happens and why
people don't give a [ __ ]
yeah and and they have to protect
i wonder other racism i feel like some
people just pretend to be like
i mean i can i feel like with
anti-semitism there's like a certain
amount of like
for most what for poor white people
they're like i roll
yeah like there's like what what they
what'd they say to you
powerful jewish person because it
almost like there's a elon gold buddy
mine
has a there's a uh he does this shabbat
telethon for
for a for
it's a charity for like poor jewish
people
and every year i'm like come on where'd
you find them
no there's one there's there no no i'm
not saying like
neil i there was a billboard near my
house when i used to live off gower
and it was like an old
lady and a young kid and they both
looked really
sickly and it was it said
something like 50 000 jewish people
live it was la or maybe it was america
or california
it was like live under the poverty line
and
live in you know poverty and squalor
essentially
to donate to and i was like
really i i've never heard of this which
is technically anti-semitism
stereotyping jewish people into being
they're all rich
but i don't think of that even middle
eastern people you don't hear you don't
see a lot of middle eastern
you know transients oh like
i'm just saying there's not a lot of
homeless middle eastern there's not a
homeless middle easterners
well they'll just live in their mercedes
bianca
it's a it's a 99 that's
1999 mercedes four-door
uh and yes it's got tin and windows yeah
i just mean our
the i guess that is it's part of the
stereotype but i just don't
see us it's more like i've never heard
of it so when you hear such a big number
of jewish people are
live under the poverty line i don't like
yes
yes of course because it doesn't
yeah it's like the math is it's too
complicated it's just
too complicated it's just like no i do i
choose to believe
that jewish people are bankers and rich
so it's just easier for my own
paperwork in my head it was only that
one billboard i've ever seen
there's no one shabbat telethon if you
go to like westwood there's a lot of
shabbat
i think i see it they have a there's
like an advertisement especially when
they're
when it's like the month of it there's a
lot of those banners
i just didn't know it was for poverty
yeah it's for
it's a jewish charity um so i think
some i think i what i was going to say
is i'd be i'd be interested to see
what anti-semitism and
sympathy for it what it was like in 1935
and 1945
because i bet in 1935 they were like
what
what's wrong jewish people and then they
were like
oh oh boy
something you were right yeah um
in the same way like with george floyd
and bruno taylor there's a lot of people
there's people still my people still
have no idea my a friend of mine bought
a house you said white people yeah
they're still so
is that yeah there's a fat there's still
my friend of mine bought a house and i
think maybe off of
adams or something and her husband's
like a doctor and whatever
black doctor go ahead no
black doctor paperwork there was
uh it said owner of this property
like it legally can only be caucasian
or white and they are black and they had
to sign this paperwork and
um it was in the attachments paper and
they pressed the um real estate agent to
find out
what that paper was and there and then
the real estate agent was like
um okay this is uncomfortable but
you know this is actually what it's like
called racist covenants and
yeah like the whatever the paperwork and
which also goes to my point
white people don't need conspiracies
that's true
they'll make you sign a racist covenant
yeah at a lawyer's office seriously
like did what why and
why are you looking at why are you
looking past the idea that there are
racist covenants
in real estate in 2020 when why
isn't that the the absolute focus of
your
activism person and and you go like
nah q anon right well the funny thing is
there is legislation only now
getting in getting past i think it's on
the ballot to remove it
it hasn't been removed we'll see if it
passes
we'll see it's going to be touching yes
and no like
we're going to see if you get a better
hope that some people get corona
i mean you literally are just told
ignore it
we we won't enforce it right and just
ignore it because
no one gave enough of a [ __ ] to take it
out of
the the legal paperwork so it's all
there
and because it doesn't really affect
white people
it's just like well ignore it ignore the
fact that you are a black couple signing
and buying a house and paying all this
good money and the person
who owned this property desperately did
not want you
i just don't understand someone has to
literally pass a law to take it out
and they still have to hope it passes
yeah there's not i told that to a white
person they were like no
i told that on the one of my racism
videos from
the beginning one of my races
i said rock had to was wanted to get a
house in the hamptons for the summer
for a month a couple three years ago or
something and he
had a white person go look in his place
because he knew that a black person even
one who looks like chris rock and goes
by the name chris rock
will not get the same what do you mean
how did a white person looking
he had a wipe on some like a a
gentleman's agreement [ __ ] was like
just you'll represent me don't say who
it's for
because if if they know it's a black
person
they will not show you all the houses
wow even griswold yes you didn't say all
that
yes in 2017 i believe that's crazy it's
insane
it's insane and they wouldn't show all
the houses yeah they wouldn't they
wouldn't
explicit as i said on the video they
wouldn't explicitly say like
you can't we have a covenant they would
just go they would start saying at this
time
yeah at this time some of our avail some
of our
inventory is a little sh they're just
[ __ ] jargon it up
yeah and make it seem like nothing
racist is happening but it's
only for black people and
so i call it whatever the [ __ ] you want
i don't if
if this gentleman thinks by the way sir
i love you
in the arby's commercial we have the
meat um
but uh by the way ving is so [ __ ]
good in those commercials it's insane
he's so good all the time he's so good
all the time and the i don't know i've
ever talked about this on the podcast
biggest gossip i've ever met in my life
oh my god that makes him better
funniest can we have him on i don't i
haven't seen him since we did the award
winning the goods in
12 years hit him up he will come on our
podcast uh you know ving's about to tell
a great story
because i asked him a question and he go
can i be honest with you brother and
then [ __ ] here he goes
he was in that um mission impossible huh
yeah
he was and he told me what he made for
every one of them
oh when i didn't even ask him that did
he make a lot of money
yes good and he and he said especially
because tom cruise got him a lot of
money specifically tom cruise got him a
lot of money
he's a black son uh black son
like one it's groans uh so what i would
say to this guy is
i don't i get what you're going for and
i don't know
how much a
demarcation of of language would
move the needle i don't think it would
but sometimes it's
just showing even if it's retroactive
like
a little respect to the fact that black
people do
struggle and receive a particular type
of racism
you know because everyone every middle
east middle east
every immigrant can experience racism
but really black people experience a
certain kind that is
targeted towards them and literally not
even towards
other more if we're going to keep races
down i mean wouldn't you keep
if you're well i don't really want to
get in the mind of a racist i'm just
saying that there's immigrants
please the door is open
there's immigrant communities that excel
that excel that that thrive
you know i don't understand they're
keeping black people down legislatively
because they
feel bad about slavery yeah but they
feel
bad about slavery and they can't process
it
because it's so awful and they've done
nothing
so rock is going to come on the show and
we're going to play
chris rock believe it or not where i'm
going to
tell you set ups from conversations and
you have to guess
okay what
yeah like rock has a the difference
between
jim crow and slavery is i won't get into
it but it's
when you hear it you're like oh my god
he's so right
like it's it's basically a bunch of
[ __ ]
dudes who would kill their wives before
they they
admit they want to get a divorce that's
why people are the black people
it's like i'd rather just keep you down
yeah press you
then admit then admit like yeah that was
[ __ ] up
my great creation
white people kind of choose not to
because it's too painful to believe
it's just so [ __ ] up it's so
embarrassing it's like
now it's the guy in the confession it's
the guy in the confession room on the
movie in the
american murder of the seven by the way
stop putting american in the title it's
[ __ ]
corny it's [ __ ] we can't all have
america in it no but that's the funny
that's even
racist like this guy they what the the
video they
the photo they showed was him with his
family looking so nice and i get
it because he murdered them and it's and
it takes america yeah
and it did happen in america but it was
around the time they were showing the
it was around ferguson i think when this
happened it wasn't and
people were saying you know i don't show
his nice graduation photo show him
looking like a thug and it's like
look what you guys do to your murderers
it's always a nice
picture of a nice white guy even when
they're [ __ ] yeah i would suggest
that that's a narrative thing
it's just i think it is like more of a
[ __ ] switch like look how nice yeah
okay well um
but now meanwhile oj's on the cover of
newsweek and he's darken
um because it wouldn't have just a
regular mug shot wouldn't have done the
trick
they darkened um yeah remember it was
that was like a
that was a scandal in 90 like 25 years
ago
when but this is this is
just oj newsweek
oh my god yeah they darkened the uh shut
the [ __ ] up that that
that is that one that's not they put a
filter on it before we had filters
the american tragedy dark and doj
dark and doji it's so darkened
yeah he it's he's two shades darker
he's black um he's the color of black
like the zero
zero zero zero yeah the pantone
pantone yeah um okay
goodbye you've got mayo yeah that's
since we're talking about rocks what's
up nolan baller
um i was just watching chris rock's
monologue on snl
uh and he did a bit where he made the
point that
walter cronkite was the most respected
man in journalism because uh we never
saw him in shorts and that
got me thinking man that sounds like
some neil writing
talking about not wanting to see famous
news figures or politicians
in casual wear so i was wondering was
that your work have you been writing for
him or
you did any work on that snl show i
think on october 3rd
anyways love the pod guys keep it up
that guy gave us his sexiest voice
it was pretty let the fud kit
i did not write for the show
specifically
i did speak to chris on the phone
and we
talked about that area
in conversation and the
good thing about talking to a funny
person
is you will get ideas for
stand-up comedy and sometimes i get an
idea
from something he says and sometimes he
gets an idea from something i said
and history will only remember the times
that he he got any
it will only favor him here's my point
like
you'd [ __ ] say that history will be
like very [ __ ] out of here
um that's fine uh yeah but that's the we
i mean a lot of the things we talk about
i've already talked to i've already
yelled at him
about this before i yell at you yeah
well i
and by and
i cut him off as much as i cut you off
too everyone's like
cut off there are times where i'll be on
the phone with him and i'll cut him off
and i'll go
neal you know this guy's one of your
favorite comedians in
your life i don't care
i've got something to say i didn't think
you could and it's meandering you just
don't like the blowback i don't think
you care
what's this what's this waitress talking
to me for that's how i
uh um i actually text you yeah
i i did the same thing yes i was like
well yeah no because
a lot of times will we will
uh he'll send me
not literally the aoc makeup video but
we'll talk about
this he'll he'll try to og
me like you [ __ ] you're your
generation and i'm like
how old is he he's 10 years older than
me um yeah
um your generation like my generation
the [ __ ] are you talking and then i'll
have
as harsh a thing as he does and then
he's like damn neil no he literally the
ronda rousey joke he did i said a
way meaner version of on the phone which
we won't get into
because it's not for everyone okay uh
but yes there are times when people
people go you and dave sound alike
[ __ ] yeah yeah but they never
i don't want to get into it don't get me
goodbye you've got mail
hey neil and bianca maya here my
boyfriend and i
are long time feelers lst and
i wanted to know what your thoughts are
on neo-hippie earth chicks that maybe
take it way too far
to dive in i have a friend who is in a
monogamous relationship
and she recently told me that she gives
oral sex
to her girlfriend while she's on her
period regularly
and not at the end of her period
sometimes on the second and third days
she described herself as being a proud
earth mama for the fact
in the moment when she told me i played
it cool but honestly i was in total
disbelief
despite my boyfriend and i considering
ourselves pretty progressive thinkers
we are both morbidly disgusted does this
violate the terms of wokeness
my boyfriend says if that's woke put me
to sleep
also is this low-key cannibalism how
nelly felly and how binky finky
i like how people it seems like we asked
people to do this we've never encour i
mean we've encouraged it i love it
it's so dumb and so so funny and silly
and that
literally they did themselves yeah
like they write it writes themselves um
well so okay
not to be an earthy chick but
okay this is gonna be a little vulgar
excuse me um but
if you take a shower uh-huh and you're
squeaky clean and they immediately put a
tampon on
i mean like that could be uh
that could be a way where
that's going to surprise a lot of people
right now i don't disagree
now i've never done it but there are
times when
let's say hypothetically i think she i
think i don't think there's any
here's here's a question and only a
woman can answer this
how let's say i go down on a woman
having her period
who's on day two of her period by the
way i thought of a period joke that i'll
never do but i should give to like
it's a very shimmery joke which is um
uh periods are like peanut butter they
come in chunky and smooth
um thank you very much um and of course
you don't but you did giggle
and it's too late um uh
how much let's say i was down there for
15 minutes
how much goop am i going to get out
gooped with
blood blood but it's some goop tissue
okay scoop sorry blood and goop
it's [ __ ] good blood and tissue okay
sorry doctor go ahead dr
dr um dr pinky
how much okay i'm gonna be honest to not
plug
and to go down there is weird for a lot
of reasons
one if you're bleeding pray for your
sheets
pray for your mattress yeah it's like so
you better have it
no reason with tough to name crime scene
for no reason
so let's mess everything up no one's i'm
never gonna
fresh out the shower on my period just
sit on my
bed so there's some the
logistics of cleaning i don't know what
the upside would be to do that
without at least like plugging it up two
you could be fine um you're not going to
get a lot because
the [ __ ] is so far above the hole but
it really depends on your um eating out
style so
lady again so if you really do i'll go
to like the lower
lower part of labia and just nibble go
ahead
is that good i don't believe anything
women say when it comes to sex
okay don't don't just if you take it all
labia like i feel like there's an angle
where you could be fine
but then i'm just going to be honest it
smells like blood
why do you want to be down there it's
not a like
great time for both so it just seems
like we're both doing something slightly
inconvenient
to say we do it yeah i don't uh
i think the bigger issue here is that
women shouldn't be going down on women
next question uh
i think that there's something i've
often wondered like
i'll be i've had women be on their
period and they'll go like i'm on my
period
and then it's like well i can still rub
the
your clitoris ma'am i don't need to
i'm not going down there head first but
i don't think it
is as well disqualifying
as you do in
as when you hear about a period in high
school we're like oh well that's
it's closed for a week yeah no it's not
close i think sex is perfectly fine
on your period there are a lot of people
that disagree
oh i know yeah i i think it really i do
think i'm not if a guy is not
comfortable i'm fine
it's like okay yeah what are you gonna
force it
if you're about your business no if
you're not comfortable i think sex
should be comfortable for everybody if
it if you're uncomfortable what the [ __ ]
am i gonna force you
i might be like come on no of course
come on yeah
but no i don't know would you if a girl
was like
would you go down on me i really want no
no i wouldn't go down on a woman she's
not a period it's
like what just give it sweetie just give
it two days
sweetheart goodbye come on you've got
mail okay
hey neil and bianca lst ner and repeat
and pete letter writer cool my voice is
too nasally for audio
anyway really enjoyed the first part of
you guys doing the nyt
36 questions looking forward to part two
fiance and i did all but the last
question tonight and it was great this
is my second go around after 16 months
after a 16 month
marriage that ended with my ex
freaked out that things were starting to
get serious
anyway since then i've noticed that
temperament
actually has way more to do with a
successful relationship than
common interest thoughts
um i think temperament is massive
i don't think it has more i think common
interests are
equally as important equally as
important i don't think there but i
think temperament
is the secret sauce of humanity it's up
there with charisma i mean in terms of
just
having a nice temper a nice pleasant
temperament
it's [ __ ] i'd pay yeah money
for a better temperament yeah i just i
stopped taking my temperament pills i
know damn it
uh no i mean it's temperament's [ __ ]
massive but but you you can have a good
temperament
but if you're like all right i'm going
mountain climbing and she's not
it's you can only i think it can only
last so
long of like well i'll see you later
right especially the first
five years of the relationship it's got
to be it can't just be good temperament
because some
i know a lot of people with good
temperament that avoid talking about
things and consider it drama it's like
god
let's just keep it even that you don't
you don't get anywhere if you don't
have the but what if you don't like any
of the same activities
to me common interest is so much more
important than humber because
i've i'm not saying you need temperament
for it to last
but someone could have a great
temperament and if you don't have that
much in common you're only bonded on one
or two
things emotionally that you you like
about the person i mean
maybe it'll be fine but i don't know how
fun of a ride it's going to be you know
yeah it's just going to be it's going to
be then what happened
yeah it's just going to be are you
having fun i'm having fun
but common interest i've the few guys
i've dated that have
we have so much in common it's just so
much more fun
they just have a lot more and even by
the way even those don't work so
look there's a lot i mean let's see
there's a lot that goes into a
relationship
outside of temperament and common
interest if you have untreated
mental health issues you [ __ ] for you
to bring that up
uh i'm going back on my bills uh
yeah yes but they're all but
relationships the level of difficulty is
so high and no one will
admit it what are you doing ayahuasca i
in the next two weeks i think where
i don't know
tell me about it do you want to do it i
kind of want to do it you can do it
can i do it when you do it yes
absolutely
are you going to do a as they say
ceremony am i going to take the medicine
in the ceremony
uh with mother um
uh i think you have to
so you have to do it in a room with
people that's yeah what if i don't know
if you have a dream
you don't have to do it in a room with
people i've found a guy that does it
you he'll just come to where you are
because my thing is like what if you
just [ __ ] your pants
well you don't [ __ ] your pants you i've
done iboga ibogaine whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call it
it's like a cousin of ayahuasca
my uncle's rich my uncle in texas are
rich
and i threw up and it was fine you're
just like
you're not like ah i don't find
throwing up that embarrassing no it's so
much worse for them than it is
i think it's funny that people have to
watch me do this i just think it's
like and it's i'm gonna feel better when
i do it
how long do you trip i i'm guessing
six eight hours damn and you don't go to
sleep
no the ibogaine i was up for
like a like two and a half days
kind of gained [ __ ] didn't even [ __ ]
my sleep schedule it changed my sleep
schedule for i'm not getting a year and
a half
for what like to what uh i slept less
i already sleep so little yeah i think i
could deal with it
uh but i wasn't tired weird
my clock was changed
awesome yeah it was great like i'm
hoping look i'm uh mother ayahuasca if
you're listening i hope that you can
change my clock
by an hour only an hour okay well i
don't we'll talk about it but
i'm interested yeah it'll be it'll be
interesting goodbye
uh you've got me this is a good question
that i've always suspected hello neil
and bianca cognitive psychologists
believe that about 40
of our political beliefs are determined
by genetics and the other 60
by upbringing and environment but
whether determined by nature or nurture
our political leanings
are not freely chosen i've always felt
like that yeah
uh if that's true it's isn't disliking
someone for being a liberal or
conservative
a democrat or republican the equivalent
of disliking someone for having blue
eyes or cuban accent
or uh or being left-handed
uh yes similar for sure
it's what
eventually if we're being honest
i believe as a society we will realize
that
every what we call natural bias
could be perceived as uh
biased yeah everyone every one of them
why don't you date asian men i don't
know i just don't like but why
you need to like you know you need to
dig deeper i've always felt like
that there are that conservatives are
almost born
because you can't
you can't reason with you can't reason
really with anybody's
i shouldn't even say conservatives it's
both
parties these independents you cannot um
you can't [ __ ] uh these swing voters
you cannot
[ __ ] talk to them uh no i think that
it's absolutely
true like that that's and i would say
it's probably
i would guess it's more sixty percent uh
genetic and forty percent environmental
well especially when i go home
i feel so much more
moderate i don't feel as liberal because
i
i have friends i'm like he can't talk
with you you're not
open you are so
far up being like this far
left leaning no no tolerance for
meeting someone in the middle or um
compromising
on your ideals so when you really are
around it i don't think it's
i think there's just more people who are
born into it
in terms of conservatives yeah i i just
part of the
a lot of places in our country it's part
of the identity
that was a thing that i wanted to talk
about
on here is that liberals are so
they can't even imagine someone being
conservative
they can't even imagine they're like
you're so wrong like you can't
understand how they have you not spent
any time with a conservative
no but that's people who if you travel
in this country a little bit
you know how [ __ ] but you don't know
why
it's the it's like the on brexit
voting the yeah it's like wow
the most dependable brexit vote
was from people who were almost
completely unaffected by brexit
yeah they were they like they didn't
like these pakis moving in meanwhile
they're
farmers so what the [ __ ] are you talking
about fishing towns with nobody yes
you're not you're on a boat and and
that's
12 hours a day you're on a boat and then
the other four hours you're talking
about your boat
i know that's the funny thing in terms
of mexicans when when
conservatives talk about mexicans coming
into the board
i'm like it doesn't affect you at all
yeah that's what i i
it doesn't weird but it's i understand
where xenophobia comes from i understand
where
being anti-abortion comes from i don't
i'm not like
what do you even think that's how
liberals are like what do you
think they can't even fathom how you
would think
for one second that i don't
yeah i can fathom it i can i can like
okay then you think this then you think
that
okay yeah i don't think that they're i
don't think that i'm morally
better than them i there's plenty of
things about being a liberal that are
morally uh vague i would argue that
there are more conservative things that
are morally vague
but of course that's what i would argue
yeah and
that's what i was arguing about three
weeks ago in that bit that chris rock
stole from me
um i'm red-handed he said on the phone
who's going to believe you i'm taking
this bit
uh but the thing about
trying to pick off people with
with in western pennsylvania and the
rust belt
it's like you have to understand how
conservatives think yeah and they don't
want to see
a woman wearing [ __ ] chucks or timbs
and they they want sold they just want
this [ __ ] they like
just do the [ __ ] they like you're not
going to sell them
on well it's better no they don't care
about that they don't care about
uh representation they don't care about
they don't care about any of that
so just appeal to that but it's a
violent no just shh
just appeal to them yeah but they can't
because they can't imagine
a person who doesn't care about
representation
right they can't they just can't believe
it
they representation matters it's
everything
um but they're not it's not everything
it's
something um oh this is a good one we
gotta wrap it up yeah
bianca's 80d kicked in no i'm sorry
goodbye
some of us have medication there's
nothing there's no ssri that bianca can
go on that would take care of this
dear neil you've got what you said about
sex and marriage in your last podcast
got to me in a way that i found myself
composing answers in my head
while trying to sleep that means the
podcast is working be honest
so now i'm letting it out there it's an
easy escape for men to blame the lack of
sex in a marriage on the woman
not wanting it and justifying their
behaviors with this
do you hear the voice of a bitter
divorced white lady in her 40s in your
head
you're absolutely right okay honey
by the way and i'm not kidding her name
is karen
bianca touched on it the switch from
being wanted and seduced to being
expected
to put out with a minimum of effort put
into it
is heartbreaking and out drying
that's a funny word it dries out
the
maybe my marriage was extreme but i
really felt the switch from
straight after our honeymoon from being
a desired woman to a
all caps wife it caught me off guard and
after five years of really trying my
best to keep the romance no kids
uh i just stopped wanting them my ex was
latinx
uh i'm scandinavian so there were some
cultural differences and my theory
is that in this culture there's a mother
complex that gets transferred to the
wife
once you're married and from there on
you're expected to tend to his every
need not very sexy
i would love to hear bianca's thoughts
on this she's not done because she is a
white woman named karen
i really stepped in it so i'm dealing
with my part of this dynamic yes
codependent
but for all the broken-hearted ladies
out there that blame the lack of
lust on themselves and thus takes
responsibility for their husband's
affairs
i'm just saying maybe it isn't all on
you
uh that she goes on but i think there's
plenty there
[Music]
don't if you know this is gonna happen
next time
don't get married who knows this is
gonna happen what are you talking about
i think
she's saying that this is the common
thing i've never
i can't she's saying don't blame don't
like guys don't put in any effort once
they're married they just expect
sex and then when they don't get it like
chopped chop
and they go they use that as an excuse
to cheat
as i said last week a ma a wedding
is the is all of the effort
i should ever have to make i'm how do i
need to be romantic
the wedding first of all isn't the guys
the woman's side pay for it what effort
i don't i i the woman's dad because
the dad's like [ __ ] get can you take
her
um does he get rid of this how much what
kind of part yeah fine party
uh yes [ __ ] play settings it's
important centerpieces
um that's
all the now i'm not even talking about
the ceremony i'm talking about the
uh the joining of everything
is the actual
version of the symbolism of romance
romance is a symbolism like i shall you
are the most important and this is like
you're the most important person so
hopefully
i won't have to renew this
every it sounds like every time i want
to have sex with you i have to remind
you
of all of the things you are to me and
and
but you're not allowed to remind her of
all the things you've done
it's like the joke i did about being in
a relationship is like
playing a video game with no autosave
where you're like oh i have to
so you can't start from the board you're
on you have to go back to the beginning
every single time when when you want to
have sex she's saying
that you have to go you have to the
where the romance go
it shouldn't be necessary if you're look
if
romance is basically you're important to
me
and you are special why do i have to
tell you something that i'm
living but how many relationships
are requiring a guy to whine and dine
them and be so romantic before in fact
so many people just [ __ ]
will's in a relationship i don't think
you have to you just [ __ ] right
don't bring it okay i'm just saying that
like you will don't you can't win
okay i'm just saying that we've been in
relationships
a lot of the time it's a quick
no-effort situation but she's saying
she that was her dude was
out trying right but this is also saying
that he
expected her to do everything like
replace a mom
uh but that's a different that's the
thing i'm just saying thanks part
no don't you blame wood thanks for that
i'm just saying that there i don't think
it
has to be a reset every time and you
have to convince a woman every time that
i do like her i do
joke did awfully good over a thousand
different audiences who didn't know that
the last audience had laughed at it
listen i
i'm sure the joke did fantastic i'm just
saying that everybody's been in a
relationship everyone understands that
there is a
you know the effort gets cut in half
you're not you've been in relationships
were you [ __ ] whining and dying every
time no you didn't have to
no you weren't no i wasn't of course not
well and it was good
that wasn't saying a bunch of from women
wanted and seduced to being expected to
put out with the minimum of effort put
into it
is heartbreaking and not trying so
there's a minimum there is some sort of
seduction and some sort of effort that
doesn't have to be like
take you out that's the opposite of of
yeah let's do it of the of the thing
you're describing in a relationship
where it's like yeah it's fun we're
[ __ ]
yeah but there is yeah we're [ __ ] it
just there's a mix
it's not always just like what what i'm
saying as a marriage
i don't think men get enough credit for
marrying a [ __ ] and a lot of times we
have to murder them
um as a result because it was not
appreciative that movie should have been
called
on a american on appreciation
for that uh well you'll mock that up for
me sweetie will sweetie
if you can throw o.j in there i'd
appreciate a very dark okay dark oj
in a um in a ski hat
um so no just a hat okay
okay um well with a mask you won't be
able to know that it's the juice
um yeah like you
can't what is okay so if a woman
is meant to put out what is the
equal but opposite what's the yin to the
yang so if
yen is you're in a relationship and you
get
sex without putting an effort what does
the woman we're
speaking very traditionally but what
does a woman get oh uh
unlimited thoughtfulness that's the
thing that women want
from guys that you'll never get and we
want
unlimited sex without asking and you
want unlimited
the hack you want his toilet seat down
but there's a million ways in which a
woman so we're both not getting what we
want so what do you think
that's what marriage is because i'm
complaining i'm that's why i'm
living the life bro yo single
i got my own set i got my boom clock i
got
my my really loud i got a hell of a gym
over there
it's quite this it's blowing up iron
paradise
the rock works out here when he's in
venice yeah
he skips the golds that's a block away
and comes here
i don't got there's no coveted my iron
paradise
and that's why i'm not married and and
if things
continue ladies
i'm not going to murder you he won't and
i'm not going to marry but he will say
buddy in a very very condescending
fellas
just basically feels like you're getting
murdered yeah uh
so i think that that the thing that men
want is
unlimited men have been shamed out of
art that thing of like just
have sex with me all the time like all
the women like you schedule
i don't yes because i don't think it's i
think it's wrong
then if you're going to schedule it then
you need to put in the unlimited thought
if you're going to have it whenever you
want from your
calendar six o'clock i'll see you there
okay then where is hard thoughtful don't
bring your period
the thoughtfulness yeah if she said i
want
it do you get plenty of thoughtfulness
70 30. no no no
we're not going back to 7 30. no how
much
thought did i put into my but getting
you a flight out of ireland
how much how much work did you have to
do you haven't licked my all you had to
do was
jesus uh all you had to do was give me
your middle name you had to go
the [ __ ] full i'll take care of it
i will be thoughtful um on your terms
yes that's the problem that you want sex
on your terms and thoughtfulness on your
time
sex on your terms thoughtfulness on my
time right okay fine
that's what i'm saying is men have been
shamed
out of our sexual wantonness
this thing of just like on demand
women just go uh that's you're talking
about a prostitute
that's gross uh never gonna happen and
then go
oh okay no no overall men are just like
okay
and whereas women haven't been shamed
out of
all the goofy things you think men
should be
you still think are viable and they were
outdrying to her
when you should just go oh this is silly
that i would think someone's going to be
committed to me
and are not committed to me commitment's
fine but this like
madame to me yeah but guys don't do it
so i don't know right but when women are
still upset about it
i'm saying i'm not going to do it and
you're not going to do the sex thing so
let's just not be married because we
both know how this is going to
work cool and you want to go to the
kennedy center wait stop bringing me
into it
it all comes back to all the things
we've done for you well play one of our
many theme songs would you because
bianca
i don't know about you but i don't have
to take this [ __ ] anymore you can stay
here and take this [ __ ] i'm
i'm gonna go we'll play the [ __ ] song
will [ __ ] we're riffing
[Music]
and then play the choral one the good
one
you think coral media
that's so good so good too too powerful
goodbye